e
hey Mr Ripple should we have pink cards
for no you don't need them for a work
session no e
it uh it being 11 o' I'm going to go
ahead and convene uh finance division
3's uh meeting for the 28th of January
uh we have one item for this 11:00
session it's a a work session on House
Bill
519 this bill was uh introduced to uh
the full Committee of Finance uh earlier
and now it's come to division 3 for uh
continued followup work I um I want to I
want to share some thoughts on this um
um I I I think uh in general there's a
lot of U favorability towards supporting
um uh this organization Waypoint and um
and because it's coming in as a parallel
item to the budget there's typically
processes that have us suspend this bill
one way or the other move it over into
the budget um if if we were to do that
um uh there be no commitment
on what value we would put on it the
request was 500,000 a year um we haven't
done all of the budget work which is why
we would suspend this one we don't know
how much money we have um we don't know
if we have any money so so that's got to
to wait um but uh I I I I think uh we
need to hear from um Miss Fox uh you
were nice enough to to hold off on your
full testimony last week I I forget your
name I'm
sorry so we'll we'll we'll bring we'll
end up bringing you all back we just
need to make sure our clerk gets the
proper spelling of your name and
stuff um all right Miss Fox uh you're up
so good morning Kya Fox director of the
division for Behavioral Health and thank
you for asking me to speak uh today so
as I indicated last week the the
department is in support of this bill um
and of this program and this program as
described last week um was funded in um
with other funds that were we we found
that were available to be able to
provide the half million dollars for the
program um 100,000 of it was for 24 and
400,000 was for 25 we have a contract I
know there was discussion about the
oversight of the shelter and we do
oversee it with that contractual
obligation
be happy to share that with you if you'd
like to see it um it was approved I
believe it was in February of last year
and um it goes through June 30th of this
year the shelter is unique and I believe
that was described pretty well last week
about the population that it serves and
the types of services that they provide
um with the dropin center and with the
cas management that is conducted with
those young adults and that includes uh
work Readiness and um finding uh more
permanent Housing
Solutions the program as I mentioned
again last week um is a key component to
two initiatives one is our mission zero
which you may be familiar with and
you're going to become very familiar
with after we we present in March uh to
this committee we
are um very focused on making sure that
if someone needs acute psychiatric care
they can get that either through New
Hampshire hospital or one of our
designated receiving facilities in the
state as a consequence of the housing
market being uh tight and the difficulty
in finding um appropriate housing uh
it's hard to discharge people once they
go into that acute setting and so
therefore the so-called back door
becomes a problem which then impacts our
ability to have people enter into a
receiving facility to get the acute care
that they need and so this shelter um
I've been in touch with New Hampshire
hospital and this shelter has provided
that back door and that opportunity for
young adults to have that up to two
weeks to be able to spend um getting
that case management and getting
everything they need in place to be able
to transition to the community it also
helps the front door in the sense that
it is a place when um a young adult does
not have another option they don't end
up in the emergency department and
potentially at New Hampshire hospital
but that they can go to the shelter and
get the services before it rises to the
level of needing that uh impatient
day this is also part of our children's
system of care and even though um you
may say based on the age group that's
addressed um it's not you go from being
um in a a youth or being a child and
then immediately become an adult there's
that really critical transition time and
this is a way that we're able to
continue to provide services to youth
who are so-called aging out um and and
have unique needs that are different
from the fully adult population and the
youth population um so we consider it
part of our children's system of
care we um have this in our budget
request that is um available on the uh
administrative services website uh
representative walner asked me what page
it's on so if you're want to know um
what page it's on it is uh page 3664 and
3665 and that is as part of our
prioritized need and with that I'd be
happy to answer any questions that you
may
have I I have about three three or four
questions but I'm happy to defer to
anyone that wants to ask questions
first representative
walner thank you and thank thank you for
giving us the page numbers so we can go
get our look through our 3,000 page um
budget
so when something is in the prioritize
needs the efficiency budget is what
basically the department says we've got
this is what we have to have in order to
run the programs that we're U presently
running and that we meet the needs of
the uh clients that we already have
since this didn't make the efficiency
it's in the prioritize needs budget
which means
that we may or may not see it in the
governor's budget and
um I didn't know if you could just
remark on the difference between the
efficiency and the prioritized
needs yeah this is a Nathan white
question for our Chief Financial Officer
or actually the LBA about the difference
between um about how you come about
developing an efficiency budget and
what's in and what's out um this happens
to not be in the efficiency budget
because of the way in which it was
funded with funds that were transferred
into the Bureau of children's Behavior
Health from Medicaid at that point in
time so because of that transfer and it
wasn't the intended or um the budgeted I
shouldn't say intended but the budgeted
um purpose then it therefore fell out of
being considered an efficiency budget um
in the efficiency budget prioritized
needs are those areas that the
department considers critical um and
that um will continue a service uh that
has been um already stood up you'll see
throughout our budget that we have a
number of prioritized needs this is
among them and and one of them um and we
submit our efficiency budget with our
prioritized needs and that is published
and then um the governor um do goes
through a process of um developing in
her case uh her budget and in this case
and and um when that is published again
I'll defer to um the LBA on how it then
appears and where um the efficiency and
prioritized needs appears um and is made
Available to You versus the the
governor's
budget no thank you did you want me to
comment on that or leave it alone I
think um there's not really a strict
definition of um what makes it into the
efficiency budget and what doesn't I
know there have been instances of
responsibilities that have been recently
added through legislation in the last
couple years that did not make it into
the agency's efficiency budget not
necessarily in the case of HHS uh but
other agencies um and whether whether
that happens on the Department's part or
whether it's a Das decision or a
governor's office decision I don't know
but it's not something that's strictly
adhered to in this case I'm not
surprised that it didn't make it in
because it wasn't actually part of the
budget process it was something that the
department chose to do um with existing
funds after the budget had passed so it
really could have gone into either one
in my opinion so so while you have the
mic hot uh let me ask you some more
questions about the the budget
apparently it is already on pages 3664
and
665 um does the that section of the
budget include a line for revenues for
donations um so I need to look that up I
don't have it up in front of me right
now that's all right it may end up being
a question for U Miss Fox uh and
Waypoint um in terms of um how how this
budget would operate I would assume that
the independence a awayo would
remain that um the state would have no
indication of the revenues that are
being
donated uh so we would have no
visibility uh after this budget process
into how our money would be our money
meaning taxpayer money gets co-mingled
into meeting the needs of Waypoint that
that'll that would be transparent to us
or or invisible to us rather until
the next budget cycle is does does that
sound about right yes it does I'm still
this is still coming up but I'm assuming
it's in the request as a general fund
request only and you wouldn't see
anything internal to waypoint's
financial operations in the state budget
right okay
um all right so so miss Fox I have some
questions um that I've never asked
before to uh the department and if
you're uncomfortable asking answering
them or addressing them that's okay um
we can talk about it later in another
meeting or something but um as as you as
you
know um the federal government uh is has
made a very hot push in the last week to
expunge Dei programs throughout a number
of federal uh programs I I expect
suspect that that those prohibitions
will come through CMS as well and be
shown up at the doorstep of DHHS at some
point um I also am aware that uh there
are several bills uh both in the Senate
and the house that are trying to make
sure that um we uh do not follow or fund
Dei policies uh in New
Hampshire um and so um so my question is
in in general
um what do you imagine the DHHS role to
be to to inform our contractors that
they shall not pursue Dei practices
should that become our
law um and and how how does the
department go about enforcing that
should should that be a lawful position
of the state and the federal
government so thank you um for
recognizing that I'm probably not the
one to answer that question I think that
that is a question for um the
commissioner and for our CFO and for our
leadership um and obviously any law
that's passed in the state of New
Hampshire we always um adhere to that
and follow through with that um but um
that's not something that I am prepared
to be able to answer at this point right
I I I I totally realize it caught you
off guard and that you're and you have
attorneys working for the Department
that would help answer that so but could
you help convey that that's kind of a
new set of questions please I'm sure
they're watching now or they will be
later and yes absolutely okay and I'll
come I'll come to you in just a moment
and and and the and the reason I'm
asking is because uh I've I've had an
individual uh share some concern uh with
me based on a quick read of the Waypoint
annual report that um we need to explore
a little bit about the eligibility and
the acceptance of of uh people that that
received the services um and uh so you
can you can stay at the table or or
excuse yourself and but I need to ask
Waypoint some
questions sure I'll step back and if
there are additional questions I'll I'll
be here all right thank you yeah I'll
come to
you come on up and then just state your
name for the record
please no at the microphone wait the the
the trick to this is to get the clerk to
write it down
properly yes yeah that's even better
that's more better
thank you hi good morning good morning
it's such a fun topic isn't it yeah yeah
so Bor alvare too CEO at Waypoint and
Mandy Lancaster director of the homeless
Youth and Young Adult Department thank
you for having us back yeah so so I'm
going to want to get pretty specific um
i' I'd like to know what your uh age
parameters are uh I'd like to know uh
what your uh gender preference and
history has been uh and whether or not
you have segregated facilities to to
protect those housed um I'd like to know
if you have um any sort of um uh uh race
or ethnicity objectives that you
actively seek to to meet as opposed to
randomly meet uh and if sexual
orientation gets to be uh one of the
factors for consideration so so that
that that's kind of where I'm going
let's let's let's do the whole you know
how how how equal is equal um I would
love to get started with that if I may
so we do serve young people in this
shelter that are 18 to 24 years old so
they age out on their 25th birthday
there is no preference and so that means
we don't select or identify a young
person based on gender or sexual
orientation and we do note that as
required by
um our federal Partners currently and
our data information systems to
understand the demographics of young
people that we serving and so the
shelter is a 14 bed
operation and it is an open room and I
would love for you to come see it so
part of this is an open invite for
anyone that's interested at this table
and Beyond to come and visit the shelter
it's a little difficult to describe
without seeing it but we do have half
pony
walls um I think that's how you might
describe it and so they're not separate
rooms but they're half walls which
provides male or
female um safety and space so the beds
aren't stacked together they're um to
accommodate young people in a singular
space and we do have two full-time staff
on at all times that are monitoring the
space they're doing intakes they're
understanding the young people that that
are there and what their needs are and
it's an awake overnight position both of
those are um and
so there isn't preferential
treatment we just accept who comes to
the center and there has been um a
historical
um recent
observation that some young people are
more likely to experience housing
instability or homelessness so we
contribute to that data through the
homelessness management information
system and it's
not we don't intentionally like select
who stays it's really based on first
come first serve as well as some
vulnerability factors like fleeing
domestic violence or leaving trafficking
situations um and we have been known to
use a random geniz generator which
speaks to equality um and that's our
current
practice and and what's your typical
census you say you have 14 beds MH it is
it are you maxed at 14 pretty much yes
and we often um each night turn upwards
of 20 young people away okay and then is
there um with the co-mingling it sounds
like it's I I haven't seen the facility
but it sounds like it's co-mingled
enough to where uh one would reasonably
concerned about sexual violence
protecting the people that that are in
there uh is has there been incidences of
of of violence or sexual violence there
has not been any reported incidences of
sexual violence because again we do have
staff up um throughout the night and
through the intake process there are
some young people that we can't maintain
safely in the space so safety is a
priority for us and if there are acts of
violence or
aggression um we respond to that quickly
and the young person would be asked to
leave and and we've had to call for um
assistance with First Responders as well
so so I'm very happy that I'm hearing
that it's a first come first serve that
you're collecting the statistics so that
we know what's happening in our society
we it's it it's important that these
Services provided by the state are
provided on an e equal basis uh free of
any discrimination either in any
direction just non-discriminatory
um have you with the state in the
contract signed um a certification of
non-discrimination is that part of the
contract I I'm looking at Miss Fox I
assume that's a standard boilerplate in
our
contracts all right but if I may Mr
chairman I do believe that that's part
of the contract um I I can't recall
exactly the language but I think uh
certainly the procedures that we have
internally speak speak to um sort of
really serving anybody that actually
comes to our door um and I wish we could
actually serve more than 14 and and
therefore when we were actually faced to
how do we decide which 14 we we said
like it needs to be random and I I would
say one of the hardest things for our
staff is when they have to make the
phone calls to the 20 youth that did not
make the bed right um so right right
right so I'm going to have some
Financial questions for you but I'll
I'll stop because that completes the I
think that subject um are there any
other
questions uh Senator um representative
Daniels right right now I'd like to keep
the topic around the whole
non-discriminatory aspect of this and
and just to clean the issue up and put
it to bed i' just like to go back to uh
uh you defined youth as being 18 to 24
uh can you define uh young
adult Young adult would as I see it and
as we've um conceptualized it in the
department are the 12 to 17 yearolds
that we serve but we do not serve them
in this shelter
environment that's a whole different
program um and set of
services does that answer your question
well yeah but it almost seem seems
flipped I mean I would think that a
youth might be 12 to 17 and a young
adult we do provide shelter services for
12 to 17 year olds in um and we have us
with residential facilities um for
shortterm stays to support those young
people that are unaccompanied for up to
21 days um in a safe environment that
has been vetted by um DHHS and so there
are three that we work with throughout
our service regions to ensure that those
young people are sheltered appropriately
reunified with family when appropriately
and we um collaborate with the division
when there's concern of abuse neglect or
a need for a more immediate child
welfare response okay so just just for
clarity you are
considering young adults to be 12 to 17
that's how I conceptualize it in terms
of the different programs that we
provide it what um reprentative when we
actually talk about this program we talk
about Youth and Young adults um that is
the population we serve we start at 12
unfortunately as young as 13 and 14 um
actually come through our doors and to
our attention and but the shelter by
licensing uh reasons is only licensed
for adults 18 um the licensing for a bed
uh has for under 18 has very different
um prerequisites that we couldn't yeah
and understand I'm just trying to work
on the definitions because over the over
the course of informational that that's
been given to us over the last week so
I'm hearing youth defined as different
things
and it's interesting to hear uh someone
being called an adult under 18 years of
age in in young adults as your
definition versus youth I would think of
as up until the age of 18 so it just
seems sort of flipped in
I think I misspoke thank you for
clarifying that I did so youth is 12 to
17 right I'm muddying the waters thank
you so much yeah I am catching up so
you're you're right young adult 18 to 24
25 thank
you so representative priest you had
your question representative seaworth
but I'd like to stay on the topic of of
uh eligibility and the the kind of the
Dei component is your question in that
vein my question is on
funding let let's hang on then we're
because we're going to come back to
money representative seaworth and and
mine too is a little on the edge I I
something said there reminded me of of
things that I heard in the public
hearing and I wanted to follow up on
this it's not about the eligibility and
admission policies I don't think so so
I'll so just just just so I'll hold mine
as well if yes sir thank you I do have a
question um regarding the
Dei uh is okay
um the state is state has a provision in
its statutes maybe Constitution that
says who they
protect um they don't
discriminate on gender race sexual
orientation
race it goes on um and that's in the
standard contracts with any nonprofits
or firms that
contract with the state and I would
imagine that would be part of your
contract
um with d HHS is that correct is that my
assumption
correct yes yes it is um so as as I
think um Mandy Lancaster um you know
talked before um we serve anybody that
actually we come in contact to or enters
we don't discriminate on Race on age but
I actually we don't also have any quotas
of we have to serve x amount of or X
percentage um and if we don't if you are
unable to serve them in our shelter
because either age or capacity there are
other services that we provide a droping
center for example where we can actually
um they can receive um services from us
as a followup uh so the services are not
just for the 14 people that are lucky to
get the beds any of those 34 or more
people out there youth homeless youth
can come in and get the services that
you provide under this
program absolutely thank you yes my M
add so we've been providing services for
um Youth and Young adults that are
experiencing homelessness for more than
40 years we have about nine or 10
different programs and those involve
Outreach uh we actually you know walk
the streets and find the youth and
connect with school systems um they
involve dropin centers we have three of
them in the state they involve housing
sometimes temporary housing um we also
uh provide um you know rental assistance
so we actually have homes that we pay
rent and with landlords um to to um home
these youth so there's a myriad of
programs and I I might be misquoting but
I think we serve about 400 um youth uh
um and young adults experiencing
homelessness umch in Manchester
alone and we can I add to that um we
also do provide Family Mediation support
and help young people reunify with
family or other kin when possible when
safe safe when parties are agreeable to
that and so the young people that we do
end up turning away each night we do our
best to triage in the moment a safe
space for them to go but we're also
working um over time to help them
identify something that is um safe and
stable and not on the streets of
Manchester so um so I have questions
again about uh admission to the resident
portion in the only demographic I'm
concerned about in this set of questions
is U is age uh in in in my experience in
the military an 18yearold and a 24 year
old are two different cultures um and I
so I'll I'll just set aside my concerns
about intermingling people in those that
such a diverse age group um and instead
um focus on what is really
uh seems on its face to be great about
Waypoint is that you're unique in
providing services to this particular
young age group and so so because you're
so rare and valuable in that regard uh
and because you have uh excess of people
seeking resident status uh what you
could look at the Census Data later and
maybe share the age demographics with us
later but so just from your judgment um
what impact would it have if if we were
to ask you uh in exchange for State
money to modify your age range so it
would be something like 18 to 23 18 to
22 with the idea that we're we're
focusing on that that
younger segment while still wanting to
fill your beds what what what what
impact do you imagine that would have
changing the upper age and still
maintaining a a a full bed
status um I so the the majority of our
young people are certainly within the 18
to
23 age range and I do agree there is
there are developmental needs within
that age range which I which again um
why it's so important to have qualified
staff versus a volunteer base to support
this
project um there was a time that we
served young people up to 21 only and
made a commitment to increase to 24 um
age out at 25 and I think the benefit
was to the larger community and the
business community and helping those
that are still young adults they're you
know prefrontal cortex is not quite
developed yet um to move
towards uh stability so that they didn't
enter into chronic homelessness so I
don't know exactly how to answer that
but I if if I I so just to summarize the
question again the main point of the
question is if you lowered the upper age
uh Point could you reduce it while still
maintaining
full status full residency status and if
so what's it feel like the right age
would be to where we could lower it and
still keep you
full I I would say we would have to look
at the data but my my general sense
without really having data in front of
me is that um Our Hope certainly because
of the programs that we provide is that
we would have identifi someone
experiencing homelessness before the
24th year of age so therefore um they
are actually using our services um in
the majority at earlier stages of that
18 to 24 what I also would say is that
housing is in such crisis uh right now
in the state as you obviously all know
well that we actually have to extend the
care that we provide to the young adults
that we serve because we cannot find
permanent Solutions therefore um we in
our programs have extended to 24 to make
sure that we have more time to find more
permanent Solutions U but in terms of
the shelter um the the very simple
answer to your question is we will have
14 bets full uh if we change the age
absolutely may I add and I'm not I'm not
I I don't know that I would direct that
I I I would I would just go back to you
and I would go back to the department
and just
say uh you know if all things are
equally horrible uh i' I'd rather have a
a 24y old without a bed than a 19yearold
and and and since this is such a scarce
resource it makes me wonder if we should
uh ask you to consider lowering that
upper age range um so that we can stay
full and and take care of I I presumably
even more vulnerable people than the
somebody a little older um but so that's
just food for thought appreciate it's a
really it's a good question and I appre
appreciate that question and um we
really did make this move to align with
HUD priorities so we are um we are a
yhdp recipient youth HUD demonstration
project and um HUD HUD
prioritized um young people up to their
25th birthday so that was also in line
with our shift so just some additional
context thank thanks now we see the the
heart of the problem of federal
government
but any other questions because I I have
some questions about money still uh
representative thank you before you get
into the money uh you mentioned that you
serve about 400 homeless youth uh how do
you count
those we have um well we're required to
use a database homelessness management
information
systems and so that's where we get that
number from and the in the information
that we enter into
hmis um is helpful in many respects but
it's been difficult for us to
extract um outcome data it's um counts
activities and demographics much better
than um we're able to count outcomes
currently and so we are launching a new
system at Waypoint so that we can use
our own um management information
systems so that we can provide the
community with better information around
impact and outcomes which is incredibly
important and difficult when um I have
to indicate that I'm sorry I don't have
that answer so um it's twofold okay so
so specifically if if one individual uh
showed up over the course of the Year 30
times at the shelter would that person
be counted as one person or 30 one
person I I do my very best to D
duplicate the data okay thank you
yes um question representative seaworth
yes thank you um a little earlier when
we were talking about the age the 12-
17: 18- 24 you
mentioned that the 12 to
17 uh you used memos of understanding to
accommodate their needs and um being
kind of new to this I want to try to get
that into a context is that between
Wayfair and Facilities is between DHHS
and facilities and kind of high level
what are we talking about here Theus
would be between Waypoint and the
licensed facilities
yes and just very roughly I'm not
chasing detail here but what is the
nature of of thatou and what is
exchanged how does it work it's pretty
thorough um contract between ourselves
and the facility and so the facility
obligation is primarily to provide um
shelter bed and baked into these
facilities are holistic programs with
clinical staff um pro-social activities
Independent Living skills groups so
those young people are also part of that
Community for the 21 days to really
ensure safety it's
24hour um supervision with multiple
staff communication between Waypoint and
that residential facility happens daily
21 days is a very short turnaround to
work with sometimes identify find where
the guardian or parent is and then make
movements um in concert with the
residential facility and oftentimes
we'll let uh dcyf know um pretty
immediately if the if it's apparent that
there's there's abuse or
neglect thank
you because we're so early in the budget
phase there absolutely no promises of
any money of any kind um could you give
us a sense of uh the impact would be if
we were to uh instead of
500,000 um made it a quar
million or 50,000 or zero those are kind
of the levels that we I think we need to
understand thank you thank you for the
question Mr chairman so um in order to
actually answer that question I needed
to put uh put U the shelter in the
context of the rest of the services that
we provide for youth um and young adults
experiencing homelets and so as I
mentioned before before we've been
providing services for 40 years and the
range of services Encompass about $4.5
million uh between all of the different
Services um we get mostly uh federal
grants uh but they often have a match or
a ways in which they don't actually fund
the whole program uh for those programs
we're not receiving State funding
currently we have to raise every single
year $1.2 million to support those
programs and for the last four years um
in spite of having to raise that $1.2
million we've lost uh north of $400,000
in that division um so when we think
about if we did not have more funds I
can tell you that there is absolutely no
way I can't personally think that we can
raise another half a million dollars to
support the shelter um uh it would be
too much uh we already have um a
significant um um event um the sleepout
uh that last year raised $400,000 we've
been doing this for about 10 years um
and we've raised every single year more
than
$300,000 we have uh for the shelter um
in in June uh June 30th of this year it
would be uh two and a half years a
little more than two and a half years
that we've been operating the shelter at
capacity um and the cost really is about
$600,000 a year so when you do the math
math in order to keep it open with the
hope that the state was going to partner
with us and give us some funding we've
had to raise additionally 1.1 million to
keep the shelter open so I I I wish I
could tell you that I had um the ability
to continue to raise we've tapped into
all of our major donors we've tapped
into every Foundation um and I think
their answer often is okay so this is a
one time and we're happy to help this is
an important issue uh but I don't think
it will be sustainable for us to think
that we can commit to uh have no funding
um in a partnership with the state and
and keep the shelter
open all right so those are all my
questions any other questions
representative walner this is uh this is
sort of your bill do you feel like
everything you'd like discussed has had
its time to be open
there I'm fine all right representative
Wier uh do you have anything
uh yes yeah representative uh Rich Neno
I just a point
of just a point of clarification is it
my understanding that the facility so
far as filling beds is 18 to 24 the 12
to 17 year olds are referred to other
facilities that that handle that is that
a is that a correct characterization
it's not a cold referral we have a
designated staff person that works with
12 to 17y olds and so they work doing
case management um you know in their
office in the facility but the young
person is right they're referred to be
sheltered in another facility but it's
it's a collaboration it's not a go here
and we're done no no but I was thinking
the question and I think you answered it
was it's just
18 to 24 that are actually uh in the
beds at that facility yes absolutely
thank you
yes okay representative PRI thank you
for taking my question and thank you
again for being here uh you mentioned
the funding for this program out of the
500,000 that you're asking the state 400
is coming from Medicaid
is that correct and 100 is coming from
the
state so um what what I would say and I
would ask for uh Miss Fox to sort of
correct me if I'm wrong when we hit a
crisis
about um if you have something to say
you can take that side mik but I'm sorry
to interrupt you no it's okay it's okay
my my hand and arm gestures were failing
no no I I got the signal it
was uh thank you um to clarify the
funding was transferred from Medicaid to
Children's Behavioral Health through a
transfer action um by the fiscal
Committee in order to have the funding
available for this particular program it
is not Medicaid eligible for
reimbursement the type of services that
they're providing and so therefore that
was just a indication by me that when we
were talking about whether it was in the
efficiency budget or not um and those
Medicaid dollars were General funds and
they remain General funds so Medicaid
really um I'm sorry to have invoked it
because it may have been confusing um
but that was just how um we were able to
fund this shelter within our budget um
as it currently stands those funds will
not be available um in the future
okay okay so for the committee last call
any other questions um for for for the
audience is there anyone that uh wanted
to speak on this topic I I have another
one I'll be back wait a second um anyone
in the audience wanting to speak okay
representative priest go ahead thank you
for taking my question again um Miss Fox
um when we provide contracts and funding
for services for
nonprofits is there a
percent
of of funds that they have to ra raise
to match it which they are doing in
their
fundraising it really depends on the
contract we don't um unless it is a
specific program through the federal
government that requires a state match
um we typically in our contracts um
don't have a required match however we
understood when we entered into this
contract that it was not the full cost
um covering the full cost of the program
and we do you're going to have the
opportunity this afternoon to talk to um
our director of contracts um to ask more
questions like this um however um I can
indicate that it it depends so we have
contracts that are 100% um State
dependent
um and then we have organizations such
as Waypoint that do a considerable
amount of fundraising I would say that
most nonprofits have some form of
fundraising for to help support their
organizations um but it does vary on
what the percentage may be um for any
particular uh funded program through the
state as a followup again to uh
Waypoint um you mentioned
that you have to raise $1.2 million a
year to provide the the valuable
services that you provide to the
state and that this particular
program of
housing uh young adults and providing
them with valuable services to
mainstream them back into the workforce
and hopefully get their Liv turned
around and provide permanent house I'm
I'm coming to the question I'm coming to
the question this service costs
$600,000 so you have to come up with an
additional
$100,000 to make this project work even
with the contribution from the state
that is correct and the original ask of
half a million dollars was um really
before we um had a full year of
understanding what the cost are um that
was my uh request to um Governor sununu
when I met with him and we we needed
support to uh run the shelter um and and
I felt it was only fair to stick to that
number uh but but you right
representative it doesn't cover the the
full cost of the program thank
you okay I I think we're done with the
questions uh I I want I want you to know
what's probably going to happen this is
this is just sort of a a foggy guess of
what the future may look like I don't
want you to worry because of the
Byzantine nature of the way the
legislature works but what what's
probably going to happen is uh
effectively uh HB
519 will will become orphans somehow
we'll put it into interim study we'll
we'll do something with it because the
the subject and scope of of the bill
we're going to we're going to go ahead
had migrated over and make it part of
our deliberative budget discussions so
it won't be lost you may hear something
about
519 itself that worries you don't don't
worry about that keep communication with
your friends on the committee don't
worry about that I I I can't make any
promises of any dollar amount whatsoever
we got a huge process we have an agency
request of 1.27 billion uh and we don't
have that much money so so not
everyone's going to be happy at the end
of the day um the other thing that might
happen to your your orphan Bill we we
may uh use it as a vehicle for a
non-gain uh bill that's going to get
heard later in proper course so so you
may actually hear about the rising of
519 and it's going off in a direction
you never expected again don't worry
about that that's just legislative uh
protocols um your your bill your issue
will be within our budget process I I
appreciate that Mr chairman and and I
want to thank really the committee for
for listening for really the good
questions and extend the invitation um
we have up um up on um next week on
Wednesday we are absolutely available
from Wednesday on um any day um any time
to actually do a tour I can guarantee
you that it will become really very
alive uh and very Vivid and very real uh
the services we provide if you uh come
for a tour would love to have you thank
you well thank you for coming you're
welcome with that uh this uh hearing is
adjourned
oh you oh oh just write write down write
down your name write
down famous
what
e
e e
this is the official two-minute warning
if you're out in the hall come on
in e
all right it uh being 1:00 uh we're
going to kick off for um division 3
Finance uh we have an informational
meeting uh For Your Entertainment today
this is a presentation from DHHS on um
critical T topics for how things really
work in the world world we're going to
hear from it systems uh we're going to
uh hear about the quality and
performance metrics used agency-wide in
Contracting and and maybe elsewhere and
uh and and and then if we have time some
public comment uh may be available uh
I'd like to make sure we're done by
three I I don't think anyone in the
audience is going to argue with that but
that's sort of no later than for me um
all right uh with
that I'd like to have um the IT director
Mr weers and whoever you'd like to have
join you
good afternoon members of the committee
Nathan white Chief Financial Officer and
I'm joined here today with David weers
Chief Operating Officer thank you um so
today is the the second presentation of
DHHS with our informational
presentations in advance of the release
of the governor's budget today we're
going to be covering covering efficient
stewardship of resources and strong
customer service and so um Dave is going
to start off by covering our it systems
and how the integral those are to the
programs and the services that we
deliver to our citizens I'm then going
to move into a discussion around
Contracting and some of the Contracting
um features and functions and and the
types of systems that we use as well as
the focus on customer service and its
interplay with the road map and then nth
too is also here and she's going to be
talking about some of the functions of
quality and performance relative to
audits Financial Integrity fraud waste
and abuse and all of this um is really
focused on a strong customer service
piece we're always looking at ways to
improve the things that we do to make
our business easier and to deliver the
services more effectively to Citizens up
New Hampshire and with that I will hand
it over to
Dave okay thank you you have two of the
most fun people people at DHHS here if
you love numbers and you love
technology if if you're not either of
those then I apologize for the next two
hours um so on page three of your slide
deck that you should have in front of
you I wanted to give you an overview of
sort of our Technology support structure
so it doesn't necessarily follow the
exact or structure that you hear in
terms of Divisions and whatnot so I want
to make sure we were coming from the
same playing field so we have eight
course service areas in the organization
um beginning with children youth and
families Behavioral Health long-term
supports and Services Public Health
Services Medicaid services economic
stability program quality and integrity
and our 247 Health Care
Facilities but those eight core services
are really um supported by a lot of
people like myself and others in the
room that are behind the scenes and
that's our Communications Group our
employees assistance program our
information services our facilities
management our human resources our
finance and procurement Health Equity
and legal and Regulatory Services I
probably left somebody out but I'll be
I'll be told later on
today yes Mr chair yes I'm looking at
this I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm looking to see
uh names of it systems like for example
uh I'm wondering why uh the eligibility
system system isn't listed as a core
system that's a very good question I
would say it's a core system but it's
not a core service so the systems
Provide support to our employees to
provide the service thank you for the
clarification so then moving from there
we serve multiple different populations
across those different services and
you'll hear that through um
presentations from our divisions of our
Medicaid beneficiaries um Public Health
Services is a population health so it's
our entire population they serve so
across the Continuum whenever you ask me
who do I serve I serve anyone in the in
in New Hampshire so it's basically all
of us in this room and anybody else that
is receiving services from Health and
Human
Services we have a little over 130
different um systems I would say if we
move to slide four we can talk about
some of the department Wide Technology
systems and so here's where you'll hear
some of those names and and I will get
to new heights are integrated
eligibility system in a in a moment but
at a high level we're trying to work
with um we're actually partnering with
Department of Information Technology to
come up with Enterprise architecture and
Enterprise plans to reduce duplicative
effort across our department and doit in
many cases is able to reduce duplicative
effort across acoss the state so with
that we we looked at different platforms
and here you'll see eight platforms that
we're focused on the first one being
Salesforce so you'll hear Salesforce um
a lot through the budget presentations
in terms if you hear from a technologist
in terms of how we're serving our
customers our clients our providers and
anyone that's in our constituents anyone
that's actually interfacing with thhs
Salesforce has been that platform
enabler for us to deploy dozens of
systems rapidly in a sustainable and
scalable
way um right now we're actually working
on a constituent management system to
try to collect information and be able
to um route that workflow that to
different areas of our agency more
effectively to provide rapid responses
and and accurate responses that we can
follow up on in the future
the next one is our portfolio management
office and so you'll hear of it as
called as an office but it's really like
uh it is its own system it uses a
technology called smart sheet and it was
configured um by our director of project
management to really manage a
standards-based approach to intake of
our projects um and be able to identify
the status of the the project in terms
of its health is it on track is it for
time is it on track for um uh for
resources is on track for money or funds
but then it goes further where we
actually focus on training over 280
people and we'll talk about that in a
future slide to be able to adopt this
solution and help move us forward in a
more efficient
manner the next um platform and I'm
trying to set this stage so you can
understand some of these components the
Enterprise business intelligence system
is a collection of different tools so
it's not just one thing um you'll hear
terminology like data warehouse you'll
hear terminology like Enterprise data
warehouse data
analytics um
Transformations um data management it's
all encompassing of all of that it's one
big platform that we've been working on
in concert with our federal partners for
the last 6 years
leveraging Medicaid funds Le leveraging
uh Center for Disease Control and
prevention funds and leveraging other
Grant funds to be able to build on this
infrastructure and we continue to
leverage federal funds as we go forward
to build on this this solution is really
where we're managing our governance of
how we ensure the privacy and security
of data it's where we assign data
stewards that are responsible for
understanding the laws associated with
with the data that they're they're
managing and it's where we identify data
owners that essentially are ultimately
responsible for how that data is used
within the department and and ensuring
that they use it in compliance with
state and federal
laws and the last one on that column is
SharePoint and so SharePoint Microsoft
teams is a solution that doit has
implemented but it's really critical to
our functions we used it I used it as
recently as maybe 5 minutes before today
to be able to collaborate on this slide
deck to ensure that we weren't sending
off 20 different versions and trying to
waste effort of different people's times
to consolidate it and one of the themes
you'll hear and this is something it
tries to do has been trying to do for
over half a century is to automate and
provide efficiencies for organizations
governments state governments and enable
people to do more with
less on the next column we have onbase
so onbase is a document management
system and retention solution so in in
our department we collect lots of data
as you know and the goal is to ensure
that we collect it and maintain it
properly in a place that we know who has
access to it
when they have access and how long are
we supposed to keep it so you'll see as
I talk about some of the road map
initiatives in future slides one of our
road map initiatives is to introduce a
more robust data retention strategy and
we're going to leverage on base to do
that the last three here we have is New
Hampshire Care Connections which as we
move forward a lot of people have heard
components of this as referred to as
closer referral as well as Point click
care or emission discharge transfer
solution the New Hampshire Care
Connections is really gold at bringing
together our health care and our Human
Service Providers in our state to
provide a more Consolidated
consent-based and privacy first focused
um solution for constituents that are
seeking care it could be Food Services
it could be Health Services it could be
Healthcare
Services right now if you go to any of
those providers they can refer you to
different websites they can give you
phone numbers to call they can sometimes
call for you but they can't actually
ensure that you get that call back and
that you get those services our goal is
to connect people to those Services more
effectively using the New Hampshire Care
Connections as one of the key
Technologies but as as good as any
technology is it doesn't go without the
programs and so the the key thing that
always keep in the back of your mind is
all these Technologies are based off of
the programs and services that you're
going to hear over the next several days
and through the house
budget the last two that we have is
everlaw and learning management system
so this past year we were lucky to be
able to identify funds that were put
into the budget to support ecovery
and what ecovery is is the ability to re
search through different technology
systems based off a keywords date ranges
or whatnot to be able to respond to um
requests like right to no requests
associated with 91a or litigation hold
um requests in terms of getting the
information for litigations historically
the department has had to identify
paralegals and attorneys to comb through
hundreds of thousands of emails as well
as documents and try to pull those
keywords out manually which equates to
hundreds if not thousands of hours of
attorney's time that could be achieved
with this tool in minutes and sometimes
hours so that was what that that system
really helped automate a lot of that
process and then the last one is
learning management system so the
department had a key um need in terms of
being able to provide training for both
our internal Workforce as well as our
providers that we require them to go
through certain training in order to be
licensed the current state system is an
internal only focus system so we
deployed our own learn learning
management system in partnership with
administrative services and Department
of Information Technology that allows us
to publish our internal trainings and
work across our department to pull those
in and not only just publish them in
train but be able to tr back and report
on successful trainings people that
haven't done the training so we can
follow up and make sure that they
perform that state and federally
mandated
training I'll pause for a second if
there's any questions otherwise I'll
continue representative Stringham yeah
in terms of uh new New Hampshire uh Care
Connections is that the system that uh
for example the uh disability providers
are are accessing and using to submit
invoices uh and get paid by the system
or um is it something else I have a
couple followups so I'll follow you
process all right I'm I'll I'll I'll
explain the methodology here again um
because representative priest I fell
into the same traditional habit of
committee
behavior when when you get when I give
you the floor go ahead and engage in a
good conver ational set a Q&A back and
forth have a dialogue um and as long as
you're staying on track and and you know
consistent you're not straying off or
getting argumentative I'll let you have
a informative conversation without
coming back for asking for followup all
the time that feels a little unnatural
let's let's just have good conversations
thanks thank you for the question um the
developmental disabilities agencies and
providers are actually using our new
height system system that was recently
expanded for managing case management
components um and I I know Karen Hebert
is here to see if she wants to come up
and correct
me no sorry Melissa Hardy I'm right okay
so I just wanted to make sure we do have
people members in the audience to make
sure that if I say something inaccurate
we can be corrected um so that New
Hampshire Care Connections however all
the providers can participate in that
for to be able to provide referrals to
other services so say someone's at an
area agency and they're utilizing the
developmental disability solution in New
Heights our integrated eligibility and
enrollment system but they find that
that individual may need other services
like um Food Services or shelter or
mental health services they can
certainly use the New Hampshire Care
Connections to do that um and provide
that referral to other
providers so kind of a followup then
where would the um uh it would you would
you use one of your systems to query
about the utilization of services within
some of the uh groups like new new
Heights or uh for example um one
particular type of service in
developmental
disability um is is that something in
your analytics for example that that is
is uh is accessible at this point
or is that still growing that's a good
question I would think that I I would
like to take that back and maybe have
that answered in a future presentation
from the program
area so we we'll make sure we make a
note of any of these questions that are
somewhat technical but also programmatic
related that I don't want to misspeak
okay thank
you you still have your mic on um you
still have your mic on uh let's let's
get closer to the mic when we talk I I
have an ADA problem I just cannot hear
very well unless people are using the
system um I I have a question about New
New Hampshire Care Connections is this
where the closed loop referral system is
that is correct Mr chair okay and then
uh I flipped through here I didn't see a
specific uh part of the presentation
related to the closed loop referral
system I I think later at another time
we we'd like an update on the closed
loop ref referral system specifically
terms of uh what it what it's costing
what it what we're doing to integrate it
with the MC's closed loop referral
systems or whatever they call it um
where you're at with the any privacy and
security issues related to it because it
was a I I I think initially I it
appeared to be a really high privacy
risk and uh I I know you've been
mitigating it I just think we need an
update absolutely Mr chair I would plan
on bringing that up in the house
division 3 um budget presentations if
that works for you right right um and
just as long as we're talking about that
um would you bring with you a list of
systems that you're decommissioning in
this budget and what money is going to
be freed up as a result of
decommissioning
systems I certainly will all right thank
you okay
yeah I have a a general question maybe
it's going to be covered later but um
how much of the systems that we're
employing right now are cloud-based and
then the second question
is is there any impact as yet on
artificial intelligence and and what you
all are doing in the informational
systems very good questions thank you um
so the first question of how many are
cloud-based
I would I would say I don't know the
exact number but more often than not
systems are going to the cloud at this
point so our the Salesforce solution for
example is all cloud-based and many of
our systems I can certainly speak to
them as I go through I will make sure
that notate that's a cloud-based
solution versus an on premise I would
say any new solution that we're moving
forward I would doubt would be on
premise unless there was a federal or
state mandate to do
so okay and then for your second
question in terms of impact of
artificial intelligence and our systems
we have certainly engaged with our
vendors to discuss options uh
surrounding artificial intelligence
however with there's a lot of concerns
about how we would manage the data how
we would ensure that the large language
model would be ours and not exposed to
um a vendor so we haven't actually
really Doven into taking our data sets
into those environments um we are
currently engaging with a vendor for our
integrated eligibility system to
identify some key key areas that we
might be able to achieve quicker
processing of like reading through
policies and procedures which are public
documents and being able to provide that
information in a quick way to our
Representatives as well as looking at
how we can manage a internal um AI
solution but right now nothing's
implemented um we are partnering with
the I know that they have some
initiatives across the state that
they're working on it thank you so okay
sorry go
ahead thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question uh earlier
today
we yeah really okay can you hear me now
oh okay thank you okay earlier today we
had a great presentation from uh on a
bill
uh that we're considering um regarding
funding for a young adults um homeless
program provided by
WellPoint and with that service since
it's funded now through by
DHHS would that fall within the New
Hampshire Care
Connections as a service that would come
up on your board and you could direct
people or towns to for these services
that they are
providing thank you for the question
representative uh I believe I would need
to dig in further to this specific bill
that you're referring to and work with
the program areas to come up with a
determination of whether or not New
Hampshire Care Connections or some other
solution might be applicable to provide
those Services is there could you share
with me the bill that you were referring
to the bill number was can can I cut to
the chase on this I think that's going
to come up in the closed loop referral
system I interpret his question
primarily to be is is Waypoint in fact
already a client in the closed loop
referral system and then therefore part
of the network and I think when you come
back to talk about the closed loop
referral system uh representative priest
if you can wait till then your questions
I think will be addressed because you
mentioned that it was a part of the New
Hampshire Care Connection so we'll wait
until then yeah I you you asked
specifically if Waypoint was a client in
the closed loop referral system that's
the way I interpreted your question
right and and he he doesn't have The
Client List in front of him so okay I
understand thank you and the house bill
is the house bill is HB
519 thank
you I do have one answer to that
question and maybe if you're okay I can
move on um in terms of where we're at
with the Clos Loop referral solution
right now as we're still finalizing our
foundations we are moving into um a
starting engagement of providers in the
next couple months um so there was an
implementation of our closeup referral
four years ago that we terminated the
contract with but actually still exists
in New Hampshire today um the vendor has
actually been providing that service for
providers not for the state but for
providers is my understanding and so
Waypoint may be a part of that Network
so I I will certainly reach out and um
make sure that um we partner with unit
us our contractor and understand how how
Waypoint fits into that
equation so moving on to slide
five I ask you a question about ever law
certainly um okay so this jumps out at
me because um I've been involved in some
right to know legislation this term
already
and and um there's a belief uh among
some of the people in the
municipalities that they can respond to
right to know just by emailing a
document um and I don't think that's
adequate for the task certainly not to
scale so knowing that you use ever law
I'm curious about licensing and
scalability is is is do we have a system
this comes from doit do we we have a
system that's capable of scaling to
support Municipal requirements to
support right to know and I'll take a
future answer on that because that's a
bunch I'll certainly take it back I
would say right now we we would be able
to scale it um but we would need
additional funding because the way
everlaw works is based off a storage
space so every case or every request
utilizes that storage space we currently
don't have enough storage to manage more
than a few cases at a time yeah don't
put a lot into it this is one of those
8020 things for 20% of the effort I'll
I'll get the answer I'm looking for
thank you Mr
chair so on Slide Five I'm going to go
through quickly the the role of the
portfolio management office I was
referring to earlier today so this the
pmo it operates underneath the
information Services um Bureau and its
goal is to really align our projects to
the Department's goals and objectives
and missions and values as we go forward
how it does that is really providing a
structured framework from which they can
we can optimize the achievements of
those
goals to so to do that we have some key
metrics that we sort of we track and
you'll see on a graph there over the
last 6 months we we have a gradual
increase so project management is a huge
culture shift in any organization that
hasn't had it over the last six years um
I know I've been I've had conversations
with the chair about being able to have
better project management in our
organization as well as members of many
of many committees in the the
legislature our goal is to continuously
improve and you'll hear that as a theme
even in contracts where they use the
lean Six Sigma um process which is very
similar to Agile um project
management but here are some metrics we
in the last year we completed 106
projects we have currently 104 open over
the last two years we've been averaging
about 200 projects a year going through
the pmo office now that doesn't mean
every project is in there there's lots
of projects that are moving forward
outside of the pmo because they they
were either quick fix
like quick Solutions like 6 weeks or
less or they didn't have um a large
resource complement and in some cases
they weren't identified as a project man
a project that needed to be
managed we then trained over 284 people
at this point in the three-day training
so Mr weers are are you are you telling
us that the project management office is
embedded in the it office in a way in
which if the project is some sort of a
clinical roll out of a new program it's
still coming through the it
pmo I I'm just curious about your
organizational
structure um I would the only correction
I would say is it's the information
Services Group so we look at the
information Services is really not just
technology it's all information and so
yes it is embedded in the information
Services team outstanding thank
you and then we
in order to adopt a change in any
organizations you can't just train the
workers that do the work you have to
also train the leaders that are
sponsoring and supporting the work if
the people that are driving the ship
don't know how the ship is to move
forward and go backwards and and dock
they're not going to be able to do those
basic functions so we went through and
trained 75 of our DHHS leaders in a
one-day training in order to give them
the overview of how we can move this
forward and this is leadership at
multiple levels within the department so
that they have the tools that they need
to work with their teams to be most
effective as you I'm a little slow on
the uptake I so I have a followup to the
pmo question so not everyone who
performs pmo functions works for the IT
department I assume you're taking on a
matrix basis people from the
organization making sure they have PM
skill that they're using the pmo
functions and and forms and but they're
still continuing to work where they
normally work you are absolutely correct
I could not have said it better okay
because that would be a lot of people
that would be a lot of people the pmo
itself is five people okay good
thanks so then moving on to slide six
because that's essentially the role of
the pmo is to provide that guidance
provide that leadership to the rest of
the organizations so that they can adopt
those those best
practices I have a quick question before
you move
past
oh okay uh on the I uh don't want to go
a lot of detail but I'm looking at the
metrics that were on uh the chart with
the metrics and maybe just pick a couple
and and say what those are and uh what
they're measuring certainly thank you
for the question so the the key metrics
that we're looking for is to make sure
that people are updating their schedules
so you'll see in Orange there's a how
many projects have at least 25 tasks and
so the goal is to try to see how often
what the the adoption is of the pmo
process another risk is another metric
is looking at risk metric metrics how
many risks have been identified
associated with being able to achieve
the goal of the project are we
identifying those risks mitigating those
risks and then coming up with a way in
which to move forward and then one of
the ones that actually is pro proven to
be really effective for our our teams is
have does the project have a charter so
a project Charter is like a precursor to
a business case in the in the private
sector it's a document that goes over
your scope it identifies the resources
that you need identifies what success
looks like and in many cases it
identifies the funding you need to be
able to be successful how are you going
to be able to support this solution both
in the implementation as well as um
ongoing maintenance and operations and
then with that it allows the project
team to identify who's the core of the
team who's the sponsor who's the project
manager who are the team members and
gets that cohesive team um teaming that
you need in order to achieve goals
without a project Charter many projects
tend to go many different directions
because they don't know what they're
trying to achieve the goal that that
again going back to tracking that allows
us to know these projects are going to
be healthier as a result of having a
charter healthier as a result of having
tasks identified in their project
schedule and healthier because they
identified a risk and had a risk
mitigation plan to address those risks
thank
you and the and the context of this is
that if we were to flash back six years
ago or so there there was no pmo
function was there and and this is
something that's been established and
rolled out and is continuing to be
developed or or have we always had a a
pmo function we've had a project
management function however the office
before was a team of four or five people
that would be assigned to critical
projects and they were a team of project
managers that had gone through
certification and could lead those big
Enterprise projects forward but we never
really implemented best practices in a
process for which the rest of the
department could adopt and learn and be
able to achieve those goals in concert
not just the four or five projects or
maybe 10 that the the five people that
were're running so we've expanded it to
more of a best practices center of
excellence and and Leadership across the
department versus a Staffing um Bureau
all right thank
you so this is your fa favorite part Mr
chair you asked about systems so here's
some of the systems that we were talking
about and I was trying to give a sort of
a diagram and this may or may not help
you visualize how information moves be
be around the system so think of
yourself as that
one person in the center there that has
the application below them and then
SharePoint teams Office 365 and Jour
above them if that one person wants to
share information with multiple people
within the the department or multiple
people across the state they would be
able to or even with providers and other
contractors that are authorized through
our Contracting process they would be
able to use SharePoint teams our Office
365 and Azure active directory for that
that sharing methodology that is all
managed by dyt for us but is a critical
component of our budget that you'll see
is a there's a transfer to doit is
called class 27 and that's a critical
component for us to be able to achieve
these efficiencies of communication and
collaboration amongst our team members
amongst our different departments within
the state and also with our providers
that we work
with now that same person will be
accessing many applications and you'll I
I listed some applications below there
from their computer they would go to a
Salesforce or the new heights integrated
eligibility system or Medicaid
enterprise system and and so forth and
so on they would log into those systems
more often than not their web-based
cloud-based solutions that they would
then access that
information those systems will connect
in the back on through interfaces secure
interfaces to other components to store
data in onbase for document Management
in many cases and retention and to do
data analytics and to do Trend M Trend
management and Reporting in Enterprise
business
intelligence yes Mr chair sorry no no no
you're doing great I I just want to do
an application of all of this modeling
to see if I understand how it works the
other the other day um we had had um
Miss santanella and uh Tilly in here
updating us on um a new kaizon project
that they had worked to develop
streamlined processes that cross
multiple departments and they're gaining
great efficiency out of it and I asked
the question is is helping you with any
of the new workflow because it their
process relied on a new workflow with
new information flow
and and I I I I don't think I was
speaking their language they couldn't
they didn't address it exactly so so I'm
asking you do do you have like a
workflow component when somebody does
come up with a new efficient process
you're able to adjust so that the
Systems Support the new workflow or are
they still doing work around manual uh
fixes when they come up with new
processes the honest answer is sometimes
both um it depends on funding and um
time so in many cases like I was
explaining the integrated eligibility
system we are doing studies with our
vendor to identify efficiencies and do
that workflow work in other cases if
something comes from um state or federal
legislation and doesn't have the time or
the funding many cases we will need to
do a manual work around to achieve that
goal so it it's hard to answer I can I
will reach back out to Chris selo and
and trishy to identify what they were
speaking to you about and see how we can
translate that for you all right so it
sounds like I had a bad assumption that
Salesforce was a sort of a universal
glue to let you do workflow workflow
management I hear what you're saying and
it is but it's not necessarily as rapid
as we would like and so it does take
time and in many cases because we have
procurement practices we have a master
Services agreement that we have to go
out for RFQ and that that time frame
sometimes results and manual workarounds
right so so if people are wondering why
I'm asking these these particular kind
of questions it's because um we're we're
going to continually have pressures to
do more with less and I see it as as
hopefully a silver bullet and the
ability for us to adjust and support new
workflows
uh in a more Dynamic basis as as part of
what we're going to need for future
coping skills and you and I have talked
about it off and on but but it's it's
getting to be imperative that we use it
as a more of a strategic tool to do more
with less 100% agree and I think just
one thing to add and you you did this in
the last session in many of the bills of
having the effective dates of the bills
allow for that it um integration allows
for the time necessary to implement when
the sometimes when we get bills either
from the federal or or state that says
effective July 1st and it goes through
the session we don't have enough time to
build the technology so that results in
manual workarounds and once a manual
workarounds in place it's really
difficult for providers and communities
to want to stop
the process and then Implement a
technology solution so that that there's
two things that are in concert is
sometimes in order to implement
Technology Solutions we need more time
to do so and it's not just money so we
do have Salesforce um licensing that we
can design Solutions we just would need
some time to do
those Mr chairman a question so um a
general question what kind of Provisions
do we have for like catastrophic
recovery of of data and information and
backup very good question thank you um
so each each contract that we go through
has a number of documents that they're
required to provide one of them is a
Disaster Recovery Solution as well as
well as business continuity planning so
when we go to the cloud um most of those
systems are redundant in many ways so
they're redundant in the sense that
their server fails it fails over to
another server and it's up and running
Within
milliseconds um they're also required to
back up the data um in in such a way
that it could be restored it used to be
um back in my day as a technical person
backup to tape it's now more back up to
hard drive and so they take the hard
drives and they put them in a different
location and the other ways that we do
in some of our more critical systems is
we have replicated Solutions in
different data centers or different
components of the cloud hosting provider
it really depends on the services that
are being rendered the the amount of
funding that we have to support it cuz
disaster recovery and continuity
planning the the better you get at it
the more expensive it gets and the and
so we do have a plan for every it system
to be able to restore um and be able to
bring the systems back up and running
and we have Coupe planning within all of
our programs to address those when we
have a disaster as well thank you
so that really takes us to slide
seven and this is where I'm going to I'm
going to try to walk you through and I
know we're about 40 minutes in so I want
to make sure that we have time and I
want to make sure you hit your 3:00 time
frame so I'm going to try to go through
this certainly have any questions I want
to answer them if I can but as you heard
the other day from the commissioner we
have three different commitment areas
and each of those commitment areas do r
r on technology to in order to implement
them in various ways so starting with
invest in people and culture so that
invest in people and culture um
initiative or commitment is really
focusing on our Workforce as a whole and
ensuring that we can hear what their
what their issues are how do we address
operational effectiveness how can we do
more with less as you said Mr chair and
through that information where we went
out on road trips um to different
facilities the commissioner went out
with on road trips with members of our
leadership team as well as doing all
staff meetings to really pull in that
information from our Workforce that is
distributed across the the state of New
Hampshire we we identified a couple
Technology Solutions that could help us
move components of that in that
commitment forward one of them was for
Recruitment and Retention so we've been
partnering with the administrative
service
on Statewide contracts with LinkedIn and
indeed as well as we post all of our
positions on New Hampshire first over
the last year we've actually seen um
really effective results from our indeed
contract as well as um continued
effective recruitment through New
Hampshire first our LinkedIn was slow to
roll up and I think that's primarily
because DHHS doesn't recruit a lot of
technologists and a lot of people on
LinkedIn were F first people on LinkedIn
were technologists it has grown to a
much larger population over the last
decade however indeed really seemed to
reach out to where they were going so
we're looking at those contracts looking
at their metrics to see how we can
squeeze more out of them and and
leverage that it also gave us some
insight into why do people why do people
leave organizations and we've all heard
lots of different reasons why people
leave organizations it's not always
money most of the time it's culture what
does that mean by culture how is your
supervisor does your
supervisor rule with an iron fist or do
they rule really LAX desically there's
lots of different ways to interpret
culture and I'll move forward through
there um but the the safety culture was
the other component so with the the
event at New Hampshire hospital
occurring we actually partner with
Homeland security and Emergency
Management to perform physical security
assessments and we've performed those
tool those assessments across all of our
district offices and we be continuing
through the remaining of our sites at
our um in our that we occupy here on the
state office complex over on Pleasant
Street as well as Hazen Drive the key
things that are coming out of there is
opportunities to look at how are we
utilizing our technology our bad access
systems um one of the big things that we
did is like everyone needs to badge in
and we try to normalize it and say hey
when you're badging in ask the person
behind you to badge in as well it's it's
not a bad thing you're not being rude or
anything like that we're trying to
normalize it to be just a normal process
and if you're visiting you'll get a
visitor's badge um so if you ever come
to one of our depart our locations and
we ask you to sign in don't think um
that we're trying to single you out
we're trying to do that to everyone
that's coming in the other one is vid
video
surveillance and so ensuring that we
have a consistent process for video
surveillance all of these
are have impacts on our budget so that's
why I'm bringing them up here those are
the monetary impacts that you'll see in
different budget numbers and you'll see
that sometimes we cut those and say we
we don't necessarily need that standard
today because we have something in place
today and we'll be able to look at it in
the
future so then moving over to the
promote thriving communities and that's
the one on the right on purple this is
again where we were talking about
different initiatives we're going to
leverage some of our different
Technologies including the New Hampshire
Care Connections where it is integrated
with our um some some of our waivers as
well as our different services within
our department to make referrals do ped
bed tracking maintain assessments um as
well as M ma manage emissions discharge
and transfers between Healthcare facil
facilities and have shared care insights
when and this is a key component that I
want to make sure when the the patient
has provided consent so we're not doing
if someone doesn't consent to be part of
the network they would still receive
Services they just wouldn't receive
Services through the digital
system the next one is docy sign so
we've been using docy sign with contract
contract management for many years now
and it's been very effective at reducing
the time at which to get signatures on
contracts it sounds silly but we spent
many days tracking people down to get
signatures on a contract that we really
needed to move forward and that resulted
in prod productivity loss we took that a
Next Level to manage consent Management
in many of our programs so the lead
program was one of the most recent ones
to add docy sign but we use it across
our department um both in long-term
Support Services Public Health and our
contracts group and I believe we're
going to be expanding it into other
areas as well to really improve
productivity and and ensure that we do
get that consent with a standard-based
approach the next ones are excel at Food
protection we've been working on this
contract for a while we've been working
with Exel for food production and all of
us that go out to eat rely on this
system and this program area because
they're the ones that keep us safe
Trisha Tilly does a much better job at
talking about it but I can tell you
without food protection we would have a
lot of interesting Foods being served to
us um at the restaurants that we go to
in the grocery stores we go so this is a
key component that we're moving forward
on that initiative and that and then
moving into
you'll see I'm I go through different
systems again asell is a cloud-based
solution um docy sign is cloudbased and
the New Hampshire Care Connections
they're all cloud-based Solutions and
sorry I didn't catch that earlier I'll
try to make sure I I go through them the
Drupal web content management system is
also a cloud-based solution that was
implemented by
do and that allowed for our department
to more effectively re-engineer near our
website in more of a client Centric or
provider Centric way before it was much
more focused on how we operate and not
how people consume our services and
we're constantly endeavoring to make it
easier for people to utilize our
services understand what the services
are understand what um the
different um technologies that we have
available to them or services that are
available to them the last three
um in I'll go into a little bit more
detail in future slides our new heights
and New Hampshire easy and that's our
integrated eligibility system we have an
initiative focused on how do we be more
efficient with that system to provide
efficiencies to the staff so again doing
more with less where we can that's
primarily because we have a higher
attrition rate in or not not attrition
rate high vacancy rate in the Bureau of
family assistance that utilizes this
system in the call center and we we're
trying to relook at that and see how we
can utilize a system to help that
Workforce and then the Medicaid
enterprise system is also as part of
promoting thriving communities and we'll
talk really in detail in the slide here
and and then the laboratory information
management system which is used in
public health to provide specimen
receipt analysis and reporting of all
lab testing that goes through our Public
Health lab
so a lot of people don't know about it I
haven't actually had a chance to visit
the whole thing but it's a really from
the outside it looks amazing and Ian
keeps promising me that he's going to
take me on a
tour
someday um and then improving customer
service being our last commitment
um there again you'll see the new
heights and New Hampshire easy the
reason why that's in there for improving
customer service is that is where anyone
that wants to en enroll or get
eligibility for SNAP tanif Medicaid and
other services they go to New Hampshire
easy make their application and then it
gets managed through New Heights on the
back end you see docu docy sign is
another component of the improving
customer service for contract management
and as as we continue to evolve that
work and then on base as we talked about
earlier for data classification and data
retention so um I'm I'm going to ask you
to keep the comments on the uh Medicaid
system to kind of more of the um profile
of the system rather than what it does
because we can read what it does it
manages Medicaid um the uh is this a
stable system um what sort of end to
life issues are we looking at I think
this is the most expensive system we
have um do we have any uh vital uh
interfaces that are due up to to make
the system more practical do we have any
additional modifications or or modules
that we need to buy in order to adapt to
new capability we're that we're required
to have I I don't need to know what the
system does as much as where we're going
and what the what the impact on on the
on the money may
be thank you Mr chair I will address the
slide eight in that way because there is
a lot of information for Medicaid
enterprise system so your first question
was is the system stable the current
system is the Medicaid management
information system yes the system is
stable it doesn't provide um a lot it
has a number of pain points that has
resulted in delivery of services being
delayed one of them being provider
management um enrollment can take a long
time because of the way it was designed
back in 2005 and subsequently upgraded
caused some challenges for us to be able
to Pivot so in terms of end of life it
is a system that is 10 20 years old it
was it was deemed end of life um 5 years
ago and we embarked on a 10-year um
replacement plan we leveraged um center
for Medicare Medica Medicaid services
strategies for modular reprocurement and
we're about halfway through um that
10-year plan and we've implemented a
number of solutions and we have Capital
funding to implement a number more to
answer one of your other questions is
how does this impact our budget um this
coming session for the the next bium
there's two key key areas every time you
expend Capital you have a maintenance
and operations cost so we're
implementing Solutions like system
integrator which is really gold at
bringing all of our systems together
effectively making sure that those
interfaces that you were talking about
that are our end of life are replaced
with standard um interfaces like smart
on fire or hl7 messaging or other es
other types of API strategies as opposed
to Flat files that are being exported
from one system and imported to another
that can cause errors in the actual
communication the so you'll see an
increased operational cost for the
Medicaid Program in order to support the
systems that are coming online however
we did um look at how could we address
um reducing some of those costs by
delaying or I would say leveraging the
design development and implementation
period that the federal government gives
us a 90% Federal match um federal
financial participation dollar match for
and so we reduced the impact on next
next bium or we're looking to reduce the
next the impact on the next Bion by
doing those types of that type of work
um but the there's also a capital
project that has been submitted and
would be reviewed by the the Public
Works committee that would be necessary
to continue the Medicaid enterprise
system um 10year plan so it's really a
two things and so the way I look at
everything in technology is a capital
expenditure and an operational
expenditure house division 3 talks about
operational expenditures but the Public
Works committee talks about the capital
expenditures but all those Capital
expenditures impact the operational
expenditures in house division 3 so
that's trying to make sure that when I
talk about those I don't confuse you
because they won't be in your budget but
they will have an impact over
time um so that that Capital um project
and I know I'm not supposed to talk
about numbers but it's out there is
$33,750 th000 and it's to support third
party
liability it's it's it's not um part of
the it's it's part of something that's
already been
published um so I didn't say anything
about the governor's budget I don't
believe but maybe I did I
apologize um but that capital submitt is
in your Mees bundles list in that aqua
color towards the bottom third party
liability call center and member
management those are three critical
components of the Medicaid enterprise
system but each one of the components
builds upon itself so we currently do
third party liability through our
Medicaid management information system
but it has not met the needs of our
program quality and integrity group to
be able to do it effectively and it and
it essentially
doesn't work as well as it's supposed to
as well as the call center management
solution doesn't it's not a single call
center we have multiple call centers so
we have play people going to multiple
different places to get Services which
is not an effective use of call center
time it's not an effective use of client
time and it actually costs more money to
the state to manage it that way so so if
you were to replay this video the the
last four or five minutes is more of
what I was hoping to get from you
throughout this presentation than sort
of the initial functionality
conversation okay cuz we we're having
Department heads and all tell us about
the the functionality of what they do in
their Department what I was what I was
hoping to get and your Medicaid
description was excellent is a sense of
how stable are our platforms what what
are the issues that we're having how
what are we doing to expand capability
um so so that that that was great if you
if you can kind of continue on that
theme on the next it systems and I
believe representative Mooney has a
question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you both
for being here uh this is a very
detailed and thorough subject and I
appreciate all the time you put into
presenting and preparing the capital
budget overseen by public works just to
reiterate $33 million of that budget
actually is part of your
department is that included in what
you're presenting to house finance or
separate thank you thank you for the
question representative Mooney um Dave
was referring to House Bill 25
Appropriations from past legislative
sessions so that's not part of our
budget that's the the capital budget
process works um generally speaking it's
on a six-year basis so an appropriation
is made in
hb25 and then two years later it's
looked at and say you know are the funds
expended is the project still ongoing
and then and then those funds are um
continued into the prior banum as far as
the authority to continue to spend those
so the numbers that Dave was referring
to is not in our operating budget it's
in Prior
hb25 uh
figures thank
you so continuing in that vein of trying
to go through I'm going to go to slide
nine on economic
stability as a results for those
questions so Nexus and New Heights are
both stable systems um Nexus is a
certified solution um with um with with
our different Federal
providers however there is some areas
that we'd like that we are looking to um
upgrade and primarily it's the data
analytics and Reporting where the the
hardware the Oracle hard the servers and
the Oracle licensing is an end of life
and so we are looking to identify how we
can move that forward um so you'll see
you may see that in the future budget in
terms of how do we
achieve ongoing life cycle replacement
of Hardware the servers and so this is
um representative Neno us for what are
on premise this is an on premise
solution Nexus is not a cloud-based
solution and so it is dependent upon a
partnership with dit where we need to
maintain the hardware maintain the
software and upgrade it on a period of
usually 5 to 10 years depending on the
vendors so in in terms of Oracle they've
they basically put end of support end of
life on some of their products so we
actually have to upgrade it to make sure
and we're in the process of doing that
right now and then the hardware itself
goes end of life over a period of right
I think the do sets the end of life
period it's usually between 6 and 10
years based off of failure
rates and so there are some of those
areas that we're going to be focusing on
and then one of the things I just want
to make sure and I'm not going to read
it but call attention to the interfaces
a lot of our systems interface with each
other across the department so they
don't work on them on their own they
they provide a key key function for the
program but they leverage other
Enterprise architecture to achieve
claims processing or other types of of
work and that the reason why we do that
is so that we don't have to implement
multiple of those
Solutions so a question about that are
are these all onetoone interfaces or do
you have an interface engine that you
can tie everything to so that's a good
question that would go back to slide
eight um we don't have a we don't have
an interface engine so we were
leveraging uh the Medicaid Enterprise
strategy um to identify a way in which
to implement one with federal funds to
help support it cuz system integration
is pretty expensive um it's a lot
cheaper if we can get 90% federal funds
um to the to the state it's cheaper to
the state but it certainly doesn't
reduce the total cost of of ownership
for the solution so we we are finalizing
that RFP it's still an RFP hasn't been
um awarded yet and it would be going to
governor and executive Council hopefully
in the next couple months at which point
we would be able to do what you're
saying is build a one to many um
interface engine and be able to build
those standards and publish those
standards and future contracts for
vendors to consume and use whereas today
it's every vendor creates a new
interface and charges us for that
interface in the future we will be
expecting that they come to The Proposal
with how are they going to consume or
utilize our standards-based approach
New Heights um on a regular basis
because of many federal and legislative
um State Legislative mandates has to be
able to change on a regular basis to
meet program needs so that system is
very stable we've invested a large
amount of money on that system it is
also an on- premise solution it is
managed um by a contract that um do um
just finished going out to bid for for a
vendor that manages the hardware for us
and ensures that it's up has a high up
time and a Disaster Recovery Solution um
that that system however
is needs constant care and feeding in
terms of enhancements to meet the
everchanging needs of our of our or of
our state in in our federal Direction so
you'll see in future
um operational budgets that we will be
asking for additional funds to to
support those enhancements and I I'll
reach back out to make sure that we
address some of this these questions CU
I didn't have all of that for today but
I'll do my best and we'll you may have
you may hear from the directors or other
parts of our department correcting me as
we go
forward and then going to slide
10 um really the behavioral health
system the web information technology
system is a stable electron medical
record system it does support the
services that you can read there today
um that is uh it's hosted by the vendor
I wouldn't necessarily call that one a
cloud-based solution because it is
hosted on the vendors data center um it
cloud is a if I Define cloud is like
hosting on Amazon web services or Google
um Google cloud services or Microsoft
off service jure this one resides just
in the the vendors could I do a time
check here y we have Contracting and
performance metrics still um um I Mr
White how do you think you're doing on
the time
availability um I Dave do you just want
to touch really quick on those or there
particular on items you'd like to
highlight just for time Bridges I I I
I'll let you know I'd like you to come
back and kind of re repitch your slides
to more of the system uh profiles the
kinds of things I was asking earlier
about you know where are we with a
stable system is it end of life what
kind of interface issues are we have
what sort of future capabilities do we
need I I I think I think that's kind of
more of um the things that are going to
have a productivity and a financial
impact that we want to look at I I
assume assume all the functionality is
there that supports the
Departments um so yep so I'm kind of I
I'm kind of ready to uh ask you to come
back with a a different
pitch thank you Mr chair I will do
so excellent so if you turn to slide 14
and thank you Dave very much appreciate
it if you readers it it was good I I I
don't mean I I just didn't communicate
well enough on what I was thinking I was
going to hear today I
apologize I appreciate it thank you very
much and I will I will create an updated
slide Deck with those parameters and we
can share it with this committee maybe
and you can see if we want you would
want me to come back for a testimony as
well excellent thank you
Dave so beginning on slide 14 we're
going to talk a little bit about the
Department's centralized Contracting
functions and HHS uh again we are a
large department and we handle a lot of
solicitations annually and we handle a
lot of contracts and a lot of amendments
and you're going to see that come
through in each of the uh budget
presentations later on after February
15th once we once we start into those
conversations and so we thought that'd
be really important just to provide
everybody with a baseline understanding
of what what contracts in New Hampshire
looks like because normally this process
is very G or very governor and executive
counsel involved and it's not something
that the the legislature really gets
directly involved so I don't want to
assume anything just as far as folks
knowledge around this so we're just
going to do a baseline uh just sort of
catch up around some of the basics and
how our department handles this so on
that first slide um you'll see we we
have that central unit and that central
unit came into being uh over a decade
ago uh and the department at that time
decided it would be more effective more
efficient to put all the contracts
through a singular unit because
Contracting is uh certain a bit of a
science it's a bit of an art and a
little bit of everything in between and
there are a lot of rules and regulations
at the federal level at the state level
at the executive Council level coming
through U mop 150 as it's referred to
its manable procedures and those are
rules that the executive Council issues
one such rule I think that a lot of
folks here have heard before every
contract over $10,000 has to be approved
by the executive Council any amendment
to any subsequent contract that was
approved also needs to go through the
executive Council and so that is a lot
that that's a lot of work it's a lot of
paperwork it's a lot of legal review
it's a lot of Attorney General
involvement and and we just wanted to
make sure that folks sort of understood
many of the controls that are in place
when we are Contracting out those funds
and the procedures that we follow in
order to make sure quality services are
delivered so uh we do um W within the
contracts team uh they see about over $2
billion of contracts and amendments go
through that team each year and now mind
that does include the MCO contracts
which uh I believe Henry is going to
talk about next week and th th those
contracts have a shared price limitation
of over a billion dollars and so that
certainly comprises the chunk of a very
large chunk of the contracts that go
through the team there we we do about 92
solicitations and so when I use the term
solicitation typically people call this
a request for proposal we also do
requests for applications requests for
Grant applications requests for bids and
there's different tools and each you you
use one of those tools depending on the
nature of the service that you're
looking for and um and and and we try to
maximize that and some take a little
longer some take a some are a little bit
more efficient but you don't necessarily
want to do requests for bids when you're
talking about services that are being
provided to people or someone's making
eligibility uh determinations that's
where we need to make sure that we get
the programmatic details correct and we
go with the vendor that has the best
score and so on the right there you're
going to see the
volume and the very bottom line there
that's 2019 and the other day I or
yesterday I guess I had presented and I
had talked a little bit about the many
improvements that the team has been
making over the years and one of the
goals one of the key goals has been to
not submit 300 contracts the last two
June GNC meetings which typically
happened and that's not good because a
it forces our providers to have to turn
around very very quickly some complex
legal documents they may not have time
to review and it's really important that
we give the counselors adequate time as
well to make sure that they have time to
review and ask the questions that they
have and so we've done a lot of work
around that to try to get that process a
little bit more evened out across each
year so it's not all happening at the
end of the year and there's forecasting
methodologies and systems that underlay
that and and did he was kind enough to
um put a shout out to the team on
DocuSign so the the process that he
referenced as far as executing a
contract it used to take two weeks and
it used to involve people driving around
the state trying to find people to to
hand sign a record last I checked I
think was about 37 minutes to have the
department sign have the vendor sign and
the Attorney General approve and that's
obviously we're doing a lot of pre-work
in advance of that but we took what was
someone driving around in a car around
the state and condense that down into
you know a very efficient process um you
know we at the time we were saying well
you can sign off on a new mortgage on
your phone why can't we do that and so
we put a little effort into it and we
ended up with a good solution so if you
move on to page 15 I am not going to go
into the detail here but this is a
30,000 foot view of the process and I've
cited many of the applicable statutes
that the department has to adhere year
to and we and another really key
takeaway here is we work with the
Department of Information Technology for
our it contracts we work with the
Department with the um Department of
Justice the Attorney General's office as
well and we also have to work with them
at multiple stages throughout this
process and
typically an RFP could take anywhere
from 4 to 12 months depending on a lot
of factors and one of the things that
we've done is we've surveyed our um our
providers over the years to say how much
time is reasonable for you to respond to
an RFP and historically we were posting
those for three or four weeks and we
made this change years ago where we
switched that to a minimum of s to eight
weeks because we wanted to make sure
that they had time to look at it think
about it and give us a solid response
because what we were seeing was we we
would just well uh they're not ready
they weren't able to give us a response
we need to delay that that date that
it's due and and so um that's one Factor
the factor where contract negotiations
don't always anybody that's ever been
involved in contract negotiations it
really depends on the attorneys you're
working with as far as how smooth that's
going to go um you know we we we
generally are able to do that um pretty
pretty effectively but sometimes there
are delays in that process that are
outside of our control because the
contractors or the providers that we're
working with just need more time with
that so moving on to page 16
principally this is more of a principled
conversation on this slide here our
solicitations because these are State
these are State dollars these are public
funds these may be federal funds they
may be General funds or other funds they
may be Governor commission
funds number one of the one really
important thing here is these are not
our dollars and we need to make sure
that this process is competitive and we
need to make sure that it's transparent
and there are laws um that exist that
require that whatever you are going to
be evaluating the proposals On th that
criteria needs to be known to all
parties that needs to be public that
needs to be posted and we need to score
consistently to that criteria and and we
we take that very seriously and that's
one of the advantages of having a
centralized unit because they're trained
on those laws and they understand them
and they know how to interpret them and
apply to them in the real in the real
world when we develop our agreements um
the centralized team has also developed
standard templates and standard
procedures and they've been trained on
these things to ensure that we we have
uh Provisions within our contracts where
we know that we're going to we're going
to get what we're seeking for and part
of the procurement process is
translating here's a program so there's
a legislative bill that that that passes
it's $500,000 towards this purpose okay
now you need to go from there into a
contract and you know obviously there's
a lot of details to be filled in there
and part of the work that transpires
with this team is Translating that into
how do we make this effective and
efficient how are you going to manage it
in the long run how are we going to pay
the contractor are we going to do
deliverable based are we going to do
cost reimbursement and and that's part
of what the team does there and we also
this the contracts team is also very
much involved in um some of the initial
risk assessment so we conduct a risk
assessment for many of our providers
where we're looking at are they
financially solvent what does their
financial history look like have they
had a change in leadership have they had
a change in accounting systems recently
have they ever done this kind of work
before and we ask all those questions
and based on what we're seeing and the
risks we've identified we make
adjustments in our contract so if we do
see a high risk we may say okay because
you're a high- risk we're going to be on
site every 3 or 4 months and we're going
to be verifying your records or we may
ask you to please provide us with your
month with your monthly financials so we
can make sure that we have a level of
assurity that um you are financially
solvent and you can deliver these
critical services that you've agreed to
deliver and the department can ensure
that our mission uh can be carried out
and and we don't we try to take a
balance because we rely on our providers
in the community to provide the services
on behalf of the state and you can't
just come in and say you know like
you're my contractor and treat them you
know like like unhuman family we have to
develop Partnerships and Meredith is
going to talk a little bit about what
the Partnerships look like as far as
like active contract management goes and
and what that looks like and so
obviously there's a fine balance between
holding someone accountable but you also
need to make sure that we're going to be
working with them for maybe two four six
years depending on the terms of the
contracts and we want to make sure that
they're delivering the services in
accordance with their mission as well as
the depart as well as the department and
the state's goals and that's a balancing
act if you turn to page 17 um so I'm not
going to go too much into detail here
but the the the bureau has continuously
made a lot of improvements to try to
make things more effective when we
listened to um our
providers in the past we had heard
complaints around the process takes too
long you know I'm only given two days to
turn this around and and we've tried to
take steps to address those things we've
also um years ago about 5 years ago or
so we also made a lot of organizational
structure changes to make sure that work
is distributed evenly which makes that
process go a little bit faster we also
have folks that specialize in certain
areas because you're going to uh folks
that have never been on this committee
for um you're going to have the other
divisions come through and you're going
to see each each area of the department
does have very specialized services and
we need our procurement specialist to
have that knowledge and develop that
knowledge over time um so there have
been some very uh cognizant
organizational changes made over the
years to try to best align our resources
to get the job done um we've also we
developed our own project tracking
system years ago and we've since
upgraded that to try to take advantage
of some of the systems that Dave was uh
alluding to earlier so that we can
forecast when is something going to
expire okay 12 months before that we
need to be talking internally to
understand is this a priority because
we're going to be working on a budget in
the coming months and how do we make
sure that we if we want to renew that we
need to make sure a we have the money
but we also need to ask the question is
the money being used effectively so that
we don't get to May and say oh are we
going to renew this I don't know is it
effective well we haven't done that work
and so that's part of the forecasting
methodology to a kind of smooth out the
work over time but B give us enough time
to really reassess things at the
organizational operational level to
determine whether what we're spending
money on is is effective and and uh
working towards our goals so I'm I I
know I'm moving through this pretty
quickly but I'm just cognizant of the
time here so on um on slide
18 if you shift ahead a little bit I've
already touched on the ongoing internal
and external surveys we do um conduct
internal surveys to both members of the
staff on the contract team to get
information from them them as far as
what what could we do better um what
what works what doesn't work because you
always the people that are doing the
detailed work are always going to know
but then we also on the flip side when
we have contracts that are approved we
ask the vendors in the community what
went well what didn't well and if we
start to see patterns in that um
obviously they're anecdotes but once you
start to see patterns that requires an
adjustment in some of the work that you
do and and that's something that that is
very much on our minds um I I already
mentioned the risk assessment so I'm not
going to go into that too much and then
I also mentioned some of the business
management systems so I'm going to move
forward into slide 19 to talk a little
bit about the road map and um commitment
3 initiative 5 in particular one of the
challenges that we've heard uh from our
providers in the community is that
invoice the invoicing process is
challenging and it's difficult and we
take that very seriously because if our
providers can't get paid that's going to
have serious ramifications for them and
the initiative five what we're doing
there is we are intentionally looking at
are there better ways to pay and ensure
that we can still make sure that the
funds are used effectively and the
services are delivered and historically
the default in that everybody went to
was cost reimbursement it was cost
reimbursement and what that means is you
submit an invoice you submit supporting
documentation to show me that you spent
those dollars on that an alternative way
of thinking is you come up with a rate
and we're looking at trying to implement
uh a more standard procedure around are
there certain contracts where rate is
going to make more sense but to do that
it takes a little bit more upfront work
and a little bit more thinking around
okay comprehensively what is this going
to cost that particular provider and
then we come up with a fixed rate and
obviously that works in unit-based
settings but it doesn't work in all
cases we're also looking at trying to
move towards more deliverable base rates
and that shifts a burden of the risk
away from the state and to our providers
at
time and and it it's it's a different
way of paying it's all it it's also a
different level of risk that that's kind
of cost shifted a little bit but in some
cases some contractors may prefer that
over the cost reimbursement it obviously
reduces the amount of invoicing work
that needs to be done because if you get
the deliverable and you accept the
deliverable you you achieve that goal
and and that's um certainly Something
That We're consider considering and
working towards uh more frequently m m
Mr White yes sir um just just a thought
on that um do you think the department
can make money by U Better managing the
the risk sharing we're doing with our
vendors or or or we kind of already sort
of in a in a good stable State there
could is there a way for us maybe to be
look at uh liability shifting or risk
shifting as a way for us to be more uh
efficient C can you define what you mean
by make
money okay so let let's say we uh do a
contract and uh we accept all the risk
associated with the contract being
completed on time versus we do the same
contract but we we we change the
incentive so that uh they pay us
penalties or or we give them an
incentive in order to uh do better
ontime performance so just by managing
the risk profile of a contract are we
could could could could we make more
money for the state basically so we we
do use liquidated damages um in a couple
of our high-profile contracts primarily
the MCO contracts the MCO contracts also
Al have um some risk quarters and other
incentive Provisions to make sure that
quality services are delivered um and
and I can certainly have Henry speak to
that a little bit next week typically
speaking though when we have um you know
a 6year million dollar contract or
something like that with a small
nonprofit provider we're very aware of
um pushing Financial Risk on onto a
small organization like that
and we don't necessarily always think
that that could be in the best interest
of the state I think related to that
we've had a lot of conversations
internally over the years relative to
establishing performance payment and
again you need a really strong reporting
system to
incentivize and track that kind of
payment and when I've talked to um
individuals at the harbor government
performance lab specialize in
procurement they work with a lot of
different states across the country
they've generally said that they have
not seen performance pay be very
effective for a lot of the
nonprofit um you know direct service
care providers um that that HHS works
with it it certainly Works in other
areas but but because of the nature of
our business it's not something that we
typically uh really encourage or move
towards just because we're very
sensitive uh to the the type of
communities that we're working with and
the providers I I appreciate your answer
and and more so I appreciate the thought
behind your answer thank you of course
and now finally one one thing that that
we're moving towards as well that I
think is really important is we're
always going to have cost reimbursement
contracts and but we want to make those
less burdensome administratively and so
we are moving towards a risk based
invoicing process where basically if you
submit all your invoices we check it and
looks good then we're not going to ask
for that information again for maybe 2 3
4 5 months part of this depends on the
risk and that initial risk assessment I
was talking about so that we can still
provide a reasonable level of assurity
that we're getting the services and
we're paying for the services that we
need but we also still have controls in
place so when the Auditors come around
we can demonstrate yes we have overseen
these dollars and internally to
management and to the legislature yes we
have received the services that we
sought to receive so that that's a very
quick I can talk about contracts all day
it's one of the things I get excited
about um my wife loves it but but but
that's all I'm going to talk about that
Valentine Day is coming
up you're right I I need to make
reservation somewhere that's a good
idea uh represent walner thank you so
this kind of goes back I should have
asked it earlier but when you're um
starting a contract particularly like
with a small nonprofit who may never
have had a contract with the state
before so what kind of help do you give
them along the way information do you
provide them I I've had a number of
occasions when um small contractors are
really confused by the process and why
they have to do all these
things yes so um we have been working
for the New Hampshire Center for
nonprofit over the past couple years and
um Robert Moore our contracts director
and Brook po Provost our administrator
within contracts and uh I believe Mickey
kellerer our grants administrator
they've they've tried to provide some of
the technical assistance training to
some of the smaller nonprofits because
there's when a you're working with the
state there's a number of state laws
that are not necessarily intuitive and B
when you're dealing with federal dollars
all of the requirements that are handed
to the department as far as tracking
every dollar so if you pay if you pay an
employee salary with federal funds you
need some method to track those those
federal dollars to make sure that their
time is expensed back to that some of
those Concepts aren't necessarily
intuitive and my on the finance team we
do from time to time get requests to go
and meet with the providers and we
sometimes assist them with developing
their specific invoice so if you ever
hear of a case of that I I always
strongly recommend that they reach out
because if they've never gone through
this before we we will help them um
there's also generally speaking during
the solicitation phase so when we post
an
RFP uh to the time that it goes to GNC
there's this sort of blackout period
where we're not able to say much of
anything to anyone about that
procurement and if it's ever terminated
we can't say anything for two years or
it's our say 21 or R say 21 G37 and it's
it's very specific about what
information we can release and I think
that was more of a risk-based
conversation when that statute took in
went into
effect any other
questions um did were were you done or
did you yes I I'll call Merith up if
she's okay did did you cover um I I I
was thinking so many different things I
I may have missed did you cover um
anything you might have done over the
last two three years to make the uh
public awareness greater for for when
we're soliciting for vendors I I I was I
was kind of hoping to hear what we were
doing to just be more public facing
about what's available to get more
involvement in competition yeah so we
we've done a couple of things um number
one we've tried to use our social media
platforms a little bit more heavily so
HHS has a presence on I think three or
four uh social media platforms and
anytime we post an RFP RFA RFP we try to
make sure that those get posted on there
um historically there was also a very
low threshold for notifying folks there
it was the more of a perception of oh
you're going to be providing favoritism
to a particular group if they're the
only ones that hear about it what we
always try to do is is we we're not as
risk averse as we once were we try to
send out Communications to known list
server list serves or groups of
organizations that are going to be
interest interested in something what we
can't do is we can't provide any special
information or advantage to those groups
but we try to take at Le at least some
of those proactive steps um what we see
on average is about four responses to
each for the last three years about four
responses to each solicitation the most
we've ever had is 40 the least we've
ever had is zero and we never like to
see Zero because that's a big waste of
everyone's time but that that's more of
the exception than than the rule for
sure of
course good afternoon everyone my name
is Meredith tus I am the director of the
division of program quality and
integrity for the department and I'm
going to be talking a little bit about
our quality and uh
performance that's right um so to start
I was kind of going to frame my
discussion around some of the some of
the uh bullets that you saw in the
presentation yesterday that were covered
related to this so that includes fraud
waste and abuse monitoring Financial
integrity and stability of providers
audits of
providers
um and developing meaningful metrics to
evaluate performance so we'll go over
each of those a little bit first fraud
waste and abuse uh we have a number of
different methods that we use to
evaluate identify deter and then recover
on fraud waste and abuse so perhaps most
importantly is um we work with our
Managed Care organizations to identify
Medicaid provider fraud waste and abuse
and that includes uh investigations that
are constantly ongoing both for us and
for our Managed Care
organizations and we have 25 last year
we had 25 referrals to the Medicaid
fraud control unit at the Department of
Justice so that's an example
of some of the types of Investigations
we do around fraud waste and
abuse question do you have like a
ballpark of what those 25 were worth are
we talking a million dollars 25 million
how how how how big a it might be it
might be around that it might be a
little less really depends on the case
right so you have some cases that are
actually worth quite a bit of money and
some cases that aren't um what we're
looking for in those fraud cases though
is whether or not there was some kind of
intent to defraud
so these are these are not necessarily
big money instances but they're
instances where we're trying to say this
provider really intended to defraud
Medicaid and they shouldn't be allowed
to be a Medicaid provider at this point
so that's that's more what those are
geared toward we do overpayment
recoveries on a regular basis that are
not necessarily related to fraud those
would fall into the waste and abuse
categories and those are worth hundreds
of thousands of dollars a
year
y uh so
also around concerns of fraud waster
abuse we have numerous Federal audits
that take place during the year there's
probably anywhere from three to five
Federal audits that take place across
the department in a year the largest one
being the state single audit which
happens of all departments and for DHHS
that usually includes um anywhere
between five and 10 of our programs
could be audited in a single year
anything that includes major federal
funding our division dpq division of
program called and integrity facilitates
all of those Federal audits so the
single audit and all of the other
individual Federal audits we will sit
with the program area with their
financial staff during the entrance
conference we will understand what the
audit's going to be about and then when
the report or findings are completed we
will read those go through it with the
program area and make sure that they're
appropriately mitigating the findings if
there are federal funds that need to be
returned we make sure the return happens
and that we document the the receipt
Nathan talked a little bit about uh what
we do to monitor the financial integrity
and stability of our providers including
our contracts and that really includes
um monthly getting financial statements
from a variety of providers we don't do
this for every contract we do not have
the capacity and it's not necessary for
every contract to get this kind of
information but for select groups of
providers we get monthly financial
statements and then we analyze those
with financial ratios we're looking at
whether they have Surplus deficits the
cash on hand their debt service coverage
things like that where we think that
there are concerns we would reach out to
a provider we'd meet with them we'd have
a
conversation um we may ask for a
corrective action plan depending upon
what we're seeing so the corrective
action plan would include something like
yeah so just being clear on what we
means we means you and your department
or you mean you go to
somebody no it would be my staff working
probably with Nathan's staff okay Andor
the program it really depends on the
program who's going to do Outreach but
we'll meet with the providers and have a
conversation around what we're seeing to
so that they can help us understand what
they think the cause is how they plan to
remedy it how long we think that remedy
is going to take right okay great thank
you we have a couple more questions
representative seaworth thank you uh
kind of a followup to what you just said
um
so you don't monitor every possible risk
you don't have the staff to analyze
every possible risk what kind of process
do you have to kind of
connect what the risks are and how
frequent it might be a problem with the
mitigation that you use and so how
what's the ROI on what you do how do you
evaluate that it's a great question yep
and I think Nathan alluded to this at
the beginning of the Contracting process
every contractor is required to complete
uh a Financial Risk analysis and and
what we call a management questionnaire
which is sort of our programmatic risk
analysis so that gives us an
understanding of their financial
standing right up front and it also
tells us kind of key key identifiers of
whether or not there could be a
management issue have they had Federal
findings in their own single audits have
they had key turnover in management
um has there been a change of ownership
things like that so so we're looking at
that upfront in the Contracting process
and then from that we determine their
risk level and from that we determine
the kind of monitoring that's
appropriate does that answer your
question representative
okay yes Mr chairman um on the this that
maybe maybe this is a covered by the
question you just answered but when you
say specific provider types what how
what does that mean uh so a standard has
been for example um um our area agencies
have always given us this information on
a monthly basis and they're a little bit
different because of the way that they
are designated by the department and
every five years we have to redesignate
them but so that would be an example of
a set of providers that's providing this
information so it's an an agency sorry
follow up an agency provider is a type
area agencies yes for our developmental
Services area agencies and what other
types uh uh other types would be cmhc's
which are also designated are substance
use
providers oh uh Community Mental Health
Centers would be one and also the uh
treatment providers for for substance
use disorder providers those are other
examples of types of providers okay
thank you
so I think that Nathan also alluded to
another form of oversight we do is
audits of providers so for Medicaid
providers we do investigations for all
of our other contractors we can do
audits those might be desk audits or
they might be site reviews but we would
actually go out and look at agency's
financial statements compare them to
things like their General ledgers their
payroll registers and do kind of deeper
Dives on specific agencies where we
think that there's some kind of risk and
we've done that um in a number of areas
we've done it for peer support agencies
um again substance use disorder
providers um public health and I think
that this year we're going to be working
with our Bureau of uh adult and Aging
Services as well so those are the types
of oversight we do yep these are all
great functions these are very healthy
things for an organization to do I'm and
I've heard you over the years talk about
capacity so what risk are we I don't
know maybe this is better offline but I
I'm curious
about whether you feel like we've
adequately covered the opportunity to
protect our s from these risks or
whether we we have gaps major gaps that
cause people to lose
sleep I think that we can always do more
right we can always do more um so you
know do I feel like we are managing the
highest risk I do but do I think that we
could do more of course could we do more
with a return on
investment I
mean just higher compliance higher
feeling good about ourselves that's all
nice but is can we make money with
better
auditing so as a government agency we
don't make money but I think you're
referring to maybe saving saving money
um can we can we save
more you know it it really depends the
the good news is most of our providers
are doing things right so that is the
good news there aren't there aren't
loads and loads of instances where we're
doing Audits and saying oh you owe us
back lots and lots of money and that's a
good thing we want that and that's
because we are doing lots of work
upfront to tell people this is what you
need to do as Nathan was referring to
when you become a contractor with the
state you have to be prepared so no
further investment to make more money
got it it's it's it's thank you depends
on the contractor I'll put it that way
all right if you change your mind
someday give me a call I
will uh so active contract management
right another one of the important
bullets yes that was from yesterday was
um active contract management to ensure
positive outcomes this directly relates
to one of our road map initiatives so it
commitment three is improving customer
service and initiative two under that
commitment is to improve outcomes for
New Hampshire residents by enhancing the
value of the Contracting experience for
partnering providers and the people that
they
serve this initiative is a combined
initiative of contracts Bureau contracts
quality management which is in my group
um and Dave weeders has talked to you
about the importance of portfolio
management of all of our projects and
our our
pmo um the head of our pmo project
management office St Hobson is on the
steering committee with us for this
particular initiative so like most of
our road map initiatives this is a
department-wide effort this is I'm on
slide 22 by the way I just want to make
sure people are following along um it's
a department-wide initiative and I'm
going to highlight just a few of the Del
deliverables under this initiative the
first deliverable is a contract life
cycle management policy which is a huge
undertaking to write this policy because
people all over the department are
involved in any single contract um we
are making pretty significant progress
I'd say the policy is about 60 to 70%
written um which is really important but
this is going to enable us to really
hone in on every single person's
function in the contract management life
cycle not just the procurement process
but the entire life cycle of a contract
what everybody's roles is and what the
expectations are uh another deliverable
under this particular road map item is
is for contracts quality management
which is under dpq to make at least one
tool available for use related to active
contract management for every phase in
the active contract management framework
and the framework is the visual that you
see on the right side of that slide so
every step every phase of a contract
life cycle is outlined in that Visual
and one of our deliverables is to
provide some kind of tool to people
across the department that they can use
for every one of those phases to enhance
the way they do active contract
management so far I'm happy to report we
have tools for the first four um and
we're working on a tool for the last one
so we do have have those
established uh and then the when you
meet
tool okay I um I'm I I was doing a quick
scan here to see if there's a contract
life cycle manager management system in
the it portfolio and I I don't see one
specifically do you feel like you have
adequate workflow support and services
within how you're doing life cycle
management now we use a number of
different items to manage contracts now
we certainly use Excel uh people can use
Smart sheet we have Smart sheet for
project management and many of these
contracts are parts of contracts um the
you'll hear about Cloud Suite probably
yeah Nathan you might want to talk about
that yeah and the the the state um the
the uh contract that the department of
administrative Services brought forward
to overhaul the existing Erp system to a
new system called Cloud Suite um the
functionality of that new system May
provide us with additional opportunities
and may also provide the the vendor or
provider Community as well as far as
being able to upload documentation into
the system that we would have access to
to provide better Enterprise management
um of everything but I I I think right
now that is still in the process of
being implemented still trying to
understand what it can and can't do but
there are opportunities there that that
my team and Merida's team are certainly
very interested in when we do arrive at
that point here uh hopefully in the in
the future not too far distant future
did did I did I hear you say that's a a
state level
investigation uh it it's a state level
system um that that will uh replace or
enhance the New Hampshire first system
and does that feel like a four or five
year timeline um I I would defer to the
Department of administrative Services I
believe the targeted go live date though
is this fall of 2025 and I'm more
interested in this just because we have
so much money flowing through the state
to contractors and vendors and and uh I
think any productivity we picked up here
would be probably useful uh
representative
Daniels thank you when you enter into a
contract uh how do you determine the the
capacity of the
organization to fulfill what your
expectations
are and when you're thinking of their
their capacity I mean that's partly
evaluated in their response to our RFP
so they're they're submitting a proposal
to us saying here's our they'll they'll
actually have to list out their capacity
in that so they'll have to say these are
the types of people that are going to be
working on this the FTE and what we
expect them to be able to produce and
we'll use that in our scoring did you
have anything to add to that no merus
summed it up perfectly B basically when
we post an RFP we say we need you to do
these specific things they come back to
us with a price and they come back to us
with the specifications that Meredith uh
indicated and then we translate those
into the contract
and then and then those become part of
the the legally binding agreement thank
you course and that would often include
a budget of those hours that they've
that they've pledged
so uh a third deliverable under this
particular road map item for the
contract life cycle management is to
have at least three new contract
initiatives that include contracts
quality management at the Forefront of
the contract planning
um you may wonder why why does it matter
that we're included at the beginning of
the process and it's because that is
really where you align the performance
metrics with your strategy so when you
start thinking about how you are going
to craft a contract the types of
services that you're going to be
procuring the types of people
individuals what kind of credentials
they need to have how many hours it's
going to take that's all your strategy
but this is the point at which we want
to sit with people and say what are the
outcomes that you're actually trying to
achieve and once we can have that kind
of conversation with them right up at
the beginning then we can think about
the kinds of performance metrics that
should actually belong in the contract
and the kind of data that we're going to
need to evaluate those performance
metrics so you know our our group is
relatively new in the department and I
don't want to leave anyone with the
impression that contracts management has
not always been happening it has always
been happening there's always been
contracts management for every contract
that we do this is just trying to bring
some best practice uh into the into the
conversation in terms of being able to
like I said think hard about the
strategy the outcomes that we're trying
to achieve and how we're going to
measure those so our goal really I think
Nathan alluded to this is to be able to
work with our vendors in real time to
say make sure that we have alignment on
our shared goals of any contract our
shared shared understanding of the
deliverables of that particular contract
and a shared understanding of the
outcomes once the contract is complete
did that contract work was the strategy
successful or was it less successful and
we should be able to understand that on
the same page as our vendor I I I still
have uh two semi significant chunks of
things to ask you about that aren't in
the slide deck um are are you are you
can you about wrap it this up so we can
shift a little bit sure yeah absolutely
um I think I'll just note that on the
last slide I just highlighted a few a
very very tiny number of the types of
performance metrics that we look at
within the department and I I did that
because yesterday I heard Senator
Daniels ask how do you measure success
and you know our our vision is Optimal
Health and well-being for everyone so
that's not something we can sum up in a
single number as Dr Ballard said
yesterday there are 300 different
measures we use just for Medicaid just
for the Medicaid Program just for a
Medicaid Managed Care Program uh so we
use we have lots and lots of measures
that we use and our work in my division
is to make sure that those measures are
clean meaning the data is clean there
are not overlapping numbers there are
not uh Missing Fields things that are
inaccurate data has to be clean and it
has to be meaningful meaning it has to
correlate to the thing you are trying to
actually measure so that is some of the
work that we do and i' I'd be happy to
go into uh more detail on any of that if
it's
helpful um thank you I'd like to throw
um chunk one at you uh and your memory
on this is probably better than mine but
the first time we kind of talked about
um all of this was uh four years ago um
maybe longer but I I I asked you to be
thinking about a a 10-year plan because
um I I I I think it's right that we're
working on contract uh metrics first but
I but you can't control what you can't
measure right and so there's a lot of
activity internal to the department that
I'd like to see performance metrics
around um and and you said at the time
offand well it'll probably take us 10
years to work towards being able to do
that so I'm just curious ious if you're
still thinking about that and how are
you about building performance metrics
internal to the
department you looked like you were
gonna say something sure I I I I think
that it's certainly a huge undertaking I
I think what's and I think Meredith
already alluded to this what's important
to understand is because of the diverse
array of programs and the various
metrics some requirements come from the
federal government from you know some
like 300 you know 300 performance
metrics alone are within the MCO program
what what we don't have today is a
comprehensive Nexus that draws all those
performance metrics together but what we
do have I is and this is part of the
commissioner's vision and the road map
is we have clear priorities around what
we want to put our resources towards
towards the goals that we want to
achieve in the coming year and and the
road map has been set up in that way in
in a way that we're going to be
reviewing that constantly it's not a
5year plan sometimes you see strategic
planning happen someone comes with a
5-year plan it goes in a box everybody
forgets about it and somebody dusts it
off seven years later and says oh what's
this the road map is something that's
actively being manag within with the pmo
resources and the p and the project
management system that Dave was talking
about earlier and we're having regular
meetings regular updates to make sure
that we can be successful with those
things now that's not exactly what what
you're referring to uh chairman Edwards
I I I believe but but the the current
state as far as having a team of
individuals that would analyze
comprehensive data across the department
in a unified way that that that does not
exist but we do have specific areas that
are looking at their areas very closely
and measuring that on a daily basis and
so the example I could give you that we
talked about today is the contracts unit
they're measuring how long does it take
to get from X to Y you know what what
what's the volume what's the type what
can we do to make that better that's
happening across the department and the
road map is really our attempt to try to
unify the entire department towards one
or not one goal but a m a multi set of
goals um in a comprehensive way but
what's also really important there is
we're also trying to drive that to drive
culture and to drive purpose
because everybody knows we're going into
a challenging but everybody already
knows that we're already under a hiring
freeze people have options right now
they have options to choose where they
want to work and if you don't have an
organization that has a good culture and
a good place and you don't understand
your purpose in that then that may not
be a place that people want to work and
and we're trying to make sure that HHS
is the place that people want to work
and that's the unifying drive but again
I realize that's not quite what you're
looking for as far as that performance
metric but but that's very important as
far as our priorities go um towards
towards the upcoming budget
conversations I so I actually think you
got pretty close to answering what I'm
what I'm kind of looking for I the
obviously the commissioner is using the
Strategic road map to manage the entire
department and as I look at the
Strategic road map as impressed as I am
with it I I I can't help but to look at
it and go okay what are the what are the
key performance metrics or indicators to
know if we're accomplishing that
component of the road map what I think I
just heard you say though is that
although I may not be seeing them the
pmo has some set of set metrics that
they're monitoring regularly and I'm
guessing that in the individual uh uh
performance evaluations you have kpis
for individual Behavior to reinforce
their support for the road map so you
got maybe at least two metrics I'm not
trying to put words in your mouth I'm
just trying to say what I think I
understand yeah I I mean there there are
systems upon systems in in any
organization and we try to make sure
that our our our sjds are the
supplemental job description it's
basically someone's job description
against which we annually measure
performance align with the Align with
the bureau's goal and the bureau aligns
with the division goal and the division
goals are consistent with stat statute
and the and the requirements upon us so
so that's all great so then my ask then
is if you could find a simple way to
communicate to me which metrics you're
using to to measure the key components
of the road map i' I'd like to I I know
what you're trying to do I just would
like a better idea of when have we
arrived or what does success look like
with this sure U and I I'm not looking
to reinvent all your wheel but if
there's already a way to just expose
that i' I'd appreciate that and if I can
just add and when we spoke all those
years ago Mr chair and and still
today much of what we do at the
department is Project based because
things are changing constantly so every
year 400 New pieces of legislation come
out impacting the department so it's not
as though you know we have in contracts
we do have some dedicated staff who are
actually just doing the same thing
they're producing contracts constantly
they're producing contracts that come
out of a lot of that legislation a lot
of the program area staff though you
know every July now have a whole new
slate of things that they need to do so
each project has a different way to
measure success and and it's often
related to time is the way that we you
know evaluate whether or not there's
success of that so there's some kind of
deadline we need to accomplish something
by did we do it or did we not do it and
and those are kind of the metrics that
we have have to use in order to to know
whether or not we were successful in
achieving what we were mandated to
do all right committee questions any
committee
questions anyone from the audience
feeling like they need to get up and say
something um I have um uh
256 um so so what have we determined
today I I think we've determined that
you all have uh done a lot of good work
and uh I'd like another bite at the
Apple at looking at the it systems um
and if you if you all could come back
with some sort of uh you know
appropriately scaled U visual for me to
understand how we know the Strategic
road map what does success look like and
and I'm sure that'll come intuitively to
you but I I just I just feel like I need
something to know if if we're
succeeding
um um I that's all that's that those are
the two big takeaways I have uh do you
have anything that you feel compelled
to correct or modify or no no we
appreciate the time with the committee
uh and uh look forward to spending many
many more days here oh okay uh well
three minutes early we're going to
adjourn thank you thank you
all
e
e e